this is the Jocko podcast Civil War
Excursion number six with JD Baker and
me Jocko willink good evening JD good
evening Jocko
at
3am I was aroused from my deep sleep by
an officer from Washington entering my
tent George Mead wrote to his wife
and after waking me up saying he had
come to give me trouble
at first I thought that it was either to
relieve me or arrest me and promptly
replied to him that my conscience was
clear void of offense toward any man I
was prepared for his bad news
he then he handed me a communication to
read which I found was an order
relieving hooker from the command
and assigning me to it
means account suggests an Equanimity
that may have been more imagined than
real
according to the messenger James a Hardy
Mead at first became much agitated he
protested that John Reynolds should have
been chosen instead that he Mead was
totally arrogant ignorant of the
positions and dispositions of the army
he was to take in charge
and that it would only make sense for
him to refuse the assignment
Hardy patiently explained that all of
Mead's arguments had already been taken
into consideration and the president's
decision was final
as Mead absorb this
some of his dry humor returned
well
I've been tried and condemned without a
hearing he told Hardy and I suppose I
shall have to go to the execution
[Laughter]
so that right there is an excerpt from
the book Gettysburg by Noah Andre
Trudeau
kind of bringing uh the union leader for
the Battle of Gettysburg we've heard His
Name a bit already
General George Mead
how he ended up taking command uh I know
this JD this this is this is kind of
your
your recommended book
for Gettysburg yeah uh if you're gonna
read one I know you've read 50 books
about Gettysburg but if you're gonna
read one this is a good one to start
with yeah I mean I think we got like
what like uh like 10 books left out here
in front of us on Gettysburg uh and and
you know and I haven't like officially
walked through and like counted how many
books there are written on Gettysburg
but I would probably speculate that
there's more books written on that piece
of dirt than any other piece of dirt in
the United States uh of Gettysburg and
of all the books you know I've read a
ton and this is uh yeah if if I was
gonna go and I was gonna get one book
uh to read on on Gettysburg of the
overall battle so I'm not so now we
can't talk about like individual people
at the Battle this is like the
overarching book of all the events that
took place at Gettysburg this is the
go-to uh by Trudeau uh it is uh to me
Mana you know it's an it's an easy read
how many pages is this bad boy few
hundred five hundred yeah maybe 600
Pages uh so get into the story here
Mead's getting selected as Commander
again he's thinking he's getting
relieved I mean two o'clock in the
morning three o'clock in the morning
knock on the door he thinks he might be
getting relieved
instead he's getting selected as the
commander oh
first of all is he the first draft pick
he mentioned some other like what about
Reynolds you know where is he at why is
hooker getting relieved what's is he the
first draft pick why isn't it Reynolds
what's going on
yeah uh I mean and of course you know
Mead is not he's not the he's not the
first draft pick
um Reynolds is I mean and and uh
Reynolds and Mead
they're friends like you know what I
mean like they get along they've been
you know now we're uh coming in we just
finished out in May now we're coming
into June 1863. uh both of them are West
Point uh guys and and even if you look
at like Reynolds I mean Reynolds was
like like the commandant of cadets at
West Point you know what I mean like
he's a big deal uh he's also a
Pennsylvanian uh but so is mead uh well
Mead was uh Mead was raised in
Pennsylvania his dad uh he was actually
born in Spain uh and then you know his
dad was a foreign dignitary kind of type
guy you know I I guess you could like
put like State Department kind of guy
he's over overseas stuff so meat's born
overseas but he's raised uh in
Pennsylvania so they're both
Pennsylvania guys so uh
uh you know just like you talked about
it at you know at three o'clock in the
morning I mean nothing good happens
after 10 o'clock at night
like unless it's like the birth of a
child you know what I mean like you get
a call but you're kind of expecting that
you know what I mean like hey you know
what I mean you know I'm dilated a
certain amount okay I'll I'll take my
phone up with me because you could have
the birth of a child that's the only
time anything good happens after 10
o'clock at night uh and and Mead he had
written his wife I mean that's the cool
thing about a lot of the stuff that we
capture about this behind the scenes
stuff that's going on with uh folks in
The Civil Wars you know back then they
they all write letters home so he's
writing a letter home to his wife and
you know in Mead Mead he doesn't get
along with hooker you know what I mean
like he's not a he's not a hooker fan uh
and him and hooker kind of get into it a
little bit so he's kind of like
basically writing his wife saying hey
honey I may be out of a job you know
what I mean like I might be coming home
like I really don't know what's gonna
happen and then there he is you know he
hits the rack and you know one of these
uh Teenage couriers uh that we talk
about you know what I mean comes over
he's got a message you know what I mean
knocks on his door comes in hands him
back and of course for probably the
first thought going through his head is
well this is it uh you know what I mean
what am I gonna do now uh because it
wouldn't be the first guy that's been
relieved in the army of the Potomac uh
and you know meat opens it up and boom
it's from Abraham Lincoln man and it's
it's your Rodeo now you're the commander
of the army of the Potomac uh and of
course his first thought is is well why
me you know what I mean like rentals and
stuff like Reynolds capable Commander uh
you know and and Reynolds was the first
draft pick uh but Reynolds didn't take
it he turned it down
um and of course there's a lot of
speculation uh that that is about
Reynolds of like why yeah okay yeah he
was a core Commander you know what I
mean he just wanted to stay with his
core I kind of get that I mean we talked
about Burnside earlier and some of the
other ones I mean he was offered it and
he didn't take it uh and I'm sure just
like with you know if Lincoln if we go
like how he talked to Burnside he's like
okay well Burnside if you don't take it
we're going to give it to Hooker and
he's like okay I'll take it so obviously
I'm sure that
uh you know Lincoln was like well okay
you know John Reynolds he's like okay
John well I mean if you're not going to
take it I'm going to put George in and
he's probably like yeah dude I'm good
with George
I could only imagine because they're
friends
you know me so I could imagine like
Reynold's just like yeah hey mate he's a
good dude uh now when you look at it you
know Reynolds uh Reynolds just to you
know kind of let uh you know some of the
folks kind of know about Reynold's a
huge fan of the guy
um Reynolds is single uh and when he's
out in California uh before the war he
meets a girl uh and her name's Kate
Catherine uh is her name and
they decide that you know the war kicks
off they're like hey uh you know
after the war you know they plan to get
married
and uh and he's like yeah if I don't
make it through the war you know what I
mean then you're gonna go to become a
nun and you're going to join a Convent
for the rest of your life so that's kind
of the deal that they have and uh so she
takes his West Point ring which is a big
deal you know what I mean and then he's
got a ring that he's wearing around his
neck
um that that's that's her ring
um
and it says Dear Kate as inscribed on
the inside of the ring that Reynolds is
wearing but nobody knows that Reynolds
has a girlfriend
and as they're coming up towards
Pennsylvania you know Reynolds being
from Pennsylvania he's his plan is is as
they're on their way into Pennsylvania
he's going to take Kate and he's going
to introduce them to his folks and let
her kind of Meet the family you know I
mean they're kind of like secretly
engaged well you know to kind of put you
in the content is
Kate's Catholic and Reynolds is
Protestant
well in 1863 it's a big deal
so that's why they're kind of keeping it
like under the wraps and he's not like
telling anybody even his staff guys like
most none of these guys know
that General Reynolds has got a
girlfriend and this is again this is
just JD kind of you know what I mean
when I kind of look at it it's like okay
well if I know I'm I'm gonna go home and
I've got like this plan kind of thing
and if I stay as a core Commander
I've got the ability to kind of swoop
away and and take Kate and go introduce
to the family if I take this gig as the
Army Commander
I'm probably gonna have to cancel my
little trip with Kate and introducing
him to the family and that's just me
kind of thinking because I kind of put
myself in Reynolds shoes if I've got
this plan I'm going to bring my fiance
to come meet the family and I'm like but
I'm going to get promoted and it's like
that's gonna screw up like I'm gonna
have to like start formulating plans and
you know I mean it's going to overwhelm
me I'm taking over a new position uh and
so I think that had a little bit to do
with the fact of Reynolds turning down
command and again I think that Reynolds
is cool with George Gordon Mead being
the Army Commander like hey dude I'll
work for that guy like any day of the
week so uh that's that's a little bit
you know we'll talk about like we'll
talk about Kate you know a little later
you know instead of getting our head of
ourselves what uh with General Reynolds
um and and Mead you know you mentioned
me don't really like hooker and one of
the things you you I know when you and I
talk about Mead we always throw the word
you always throw the word like he's an
engineer like this is the kind of
personnel you know you have that
stereotypical personality of what an
engineer is this is an analytical person
he's a thoughtful person he's a cerebral
person and we're gonna see that conduct
he has the mindset of an engineer
throughout this throughout the
Gettysburg campaign for sure right
yeah he's uh yeah Mead is uh
I mean yeah he's just he's different uh
but the the thing that you know if you
if you if you pull the string a little
bit on on George Gordon Mead even at the
at the start of the Civil War of the
battles that we've already discovered
like meat is the he's he broke Jackson's
lines at Fredericksburg made it all the
way you know up the the uh the River
Road could have gotten in and behind I
mean this dude is is like shows success
uh he's not the guy that gets invited to
the barbecue on Saturday man you know
what I mean like he's not one of those
individuals he's the fun guy to be
around he's an engineer he's very
methodical you know what I mean that's
just that's that's just how he's wired
and the cool thing about like meat is is
he doesn't give a [__] you know what I
mean he just wants to show up and the
dude goes to work he wants to win uh you
know what I mean and he's going to
support you know you didn't hear
anything like we talked about like some
of the other commanders like undermining
you know leadership and stuff like that
like of all the stuff and I mean we've
got another book of course laying there
you know meet at Gettysburg uh you know
a study of him and command that you know
of all the books that I've read like
I've never heard of mead like yeah he
might be sending a note to his wife kind
of saying like yeah hey I really don't
like hooker okay good on him you know
what I mean that he doesn't like hooker
but he's still following orders like you
know what I mean he's still you know
what I mean going with the plan he's not
sending Folks up to DC he wasn't
jockeying
to be next
which that says a lot about the
character of George Ward me yeah that's
a positive thing
um
so last episode we left off at
Chancellorsville uh the union had been
defeated again
uh now this is only only a month's gone
by this isn't like some huge you know
last episode we don't we're only going a
month fast forward
uh but what's going on we got Mead now
went from division to to court now he's
the Army Commander
uh
there's also we were talking about how
attrition
has impacted these two military forces
so talk to me about how attrition
well first of all there's multiple types
of attrition but you know you can get
fired you can get you can get uh killed
you can get wounded
you can get moved so there's there's
things that can happen to an army leader
how is attrition working out for the
Union
I would say that due to attrition
the union is getting better
uh you know if you look at it at the you
know the 1860 1861 when everybody's kind
of jockeying for like who's going to get
a general you know uh who's who's gonna
you know who's gonna be in charge who's
gonna get a division who's going to be
the core commanders and stuff like that
and you know when we talk all the way
back and and even on both western side
uh the Western theater and you know this
Eastern theater of the army of the
Potomac that we've been you know
chit-chatting about uh over the past
time I mean
if you took a photo of the officers of
the army of the Potomac in in 1861.
Mead is like that dude that like have
you ever been in like like one of those
group photos and and you like you send
it to your folks like hey can you see me
that's my left ear you know what I mean
because I'm all the way in the back you
know what I mean and like all the other
folks like McClellan and Burnside and
Franklin and Sumner and all these dudes
that like they're not even in the army
of the Potomac anymore they're all in
the front
so due to them like like you said I mean
there's multiple reasons you know what I
mean they resign they get moved they got
killed uh you know what I mean they got
fired all of those reasons now if you
took a photo of the army or the Potomac
in June of 1863. you're not just seeing
like the the left ear of mead in the
back the dude's sitting front row man
uh and he's up there with who else
Reynolds Hancock you know what I mean
even you know other guys that you know
we'll talk about you know today of of
Chamberlain uh you know I mean some of
these folks that are just moving up so
they're getting better uh because
finally like the cream is starting to
rise to the top uh and it you know it's
no joke of with me that like I'm a huge
Mead fan I mean I like George Gordon
Mead and it's not just not just because
of his actions at Gettysburg but like
throughout the so far in the Civil War I
like John Reynolds Hancock I mean these
guys are proven they're working their
way up and then you look West
you know what I mean you got a dude that
at this exact time that we're talking
about that's going on as they're making
this next uh away game in Pennsylvania
before the Battle of Gettysburg
Vicksburg is under siege by that dude
who was selling firewood man on the
streets of St Louis that Grant guy I
think he's on a 50 bill now or something
uh so probably he must have been banging
it and where's that other crazy guy
Sherman that started out the beginning
remember like at the very beginning we
talked about like Sherman and I was
telling the story of him and they're
going in to like get their Rank and he
comes out and he's a colonel and people
are like dude you could have easily got
in general he's like I'll take Colonel
I'll earn General well guess what 63
Sherman's a freaking General
I mean so the the cream is starting to
rise due to attrition uh yeah we're
getting the likes of some of these
phenomenal leaders uh in my opinion with
the the Union Army now on the other side
for the Confederates how's attrition
working out for them
well you know at the beginning so again
let's let's uh you know you you peel
that back a little bit you look back in
61. I mean who was the number one draft
pick uh you know what I mean and for
Winfield Scott and Abraham Lincoln was
Robert E Lee so Robert E Lee and we
talked about like Robert E Lee uh
you know we talked about Buchanan and
stuff like that everybody you know a lot
of the varsity folks ended up going uh
with the Confederacy and if you look at
it mainly uh the army of Northern
Virginia there's going to be a change
here because at Chancellorsville as as
we know uh Stonewall Jackson uh ended up
dying uh of wounds received in the
battle uh you know sometime later so
Robert E Lee's got to find her like okay
who's going to be my my second core
Commander you know he's still got the
old war horse he's got his first core so
at Chancellorsville if you looked at the
overall if you look at the structure of
the army of Northern Virginia you know
you've got
first core James Longstreet Second Court
Stonewall Jackson Stonewall Jackson's
gone so you and I would obviously assume
that okay I'm gonna take one of the
division commanders and I'm gonna
promote them up to make them the new
core Commander uh so he's got choices
you've got like AP Hill we heard about
him uh you know what I mean at
Chancellorsville uh I mean he could even
if he wanted to I mean hell if I mean
it's Robert E Lee he could go get Stuart
and say hey dude you did a pretty
banging job as core Commander once you
give up the Cavalry now do I think
Stewart's going to give up the ponies
you know what I mean and go hang out
with the Infantry he's like nah I kind
of did my bed I'm going back to Calvary
but he could if he wanted to he could
select anybody he wants uh Robert E Lee
ends up for some odd reason
he's going to create a third core
and he's going to now have three core
commanders so he's going to have long
Street then he's going to have Yule and
Hill so he's going to create two more so
remember you know in in the in the uh
future in the in the episodes we already
kind of talked about at the beginning
you know they were a very flat
organization Robert E Lee only had to
deal with Long Street in Jackson
who each of whom he knew very well yes
now it's not saying that like Yule and
Hill and some of these other guys but
they've been operating underneath
Jackson
and we kind of talked about how Jackson
had trust issues you know what I mean
and Jackson was very close hold with his
information so you know when I kind of
look at it you know and with Stonewall
Jackson
um
it seems like he wasn't growing
for someone to take his place he wasn't
growing the people beneath him yes he
wasn't creating subordinate leaders that
were ready to step up and take his job
right I mean you know we've talked at
numerous lengths of you know number one
job of a leader make more freaking
leaders man you know what I mean make
make as many leaders as you can you
can't have enough leaders uh and Jackson
I mean for some odd reason he
it wasn't like clear enough to be like
you would kind of think that like Robert
E Lee would already know yeah if Jackson
goes down man Hill's getting the gig you
mean like automatically no one out of
the two get like rack and stack you know
what I mean like how it is like modern
day in the military like you're ranking
your people out you know who's next uh
and then you know so he's also got this
this issue okay yeah he's got a major
victory it's may we finished out with
the Battle of Chancellorsville greatest
tank uh flank attack history of the
world JD's Vineyard uh and now he's got
to decide of what he's going to do
because he's got a boss so he's got
Jefferson Davis and Jefferson Davis
again we've got this Siege going on in
in Vicksburg well this The Siege in
Vicksburg of why it's so important is
going to take you back to the Anaconda
Plan that waterborne snake you know the
Winfield Scott kind of plan this is like
the last little piece if if we lose
Vicksburg Confederate the Union's gonna
control the Mississippi
that that is and now they can start that
constrict
of constricting the South so Vicksburg
is huge and you know and uh and Ulysses
S Grant's down there laying the wood to
them uh and and Jefferson Davis is kind
of like okay yeah that's great that you
kind of dealt with that hey thumbs up
man on the chancesville thing I hate to
hear about what happened to Stonewall uh
you know what I mean but you know who
you're going to replace with Stonewall
who's gonna be a core commander and I
think I'm gonna send you down to
Vicksburg man because if I send you down
there and you can get in the rear and
threaten Grant that's going to relieve
the people in in Vicksburg and and we're
going to keep the Mississippi
so that's that's pretty big you know
what I mean if you're kind of looking at
because you lose Vicksburg man here
comes that constrictor
uh and Robert E Lee convinces you know
his boss Davis that well how about I go
north again man
you know if I threaten to the north
that might sway it's 63 what happens to
64. there's another election you know
what I mean some of the former
commanders are running on that ticket
against Abraham Lincoln talking about
Little Mac yeah mcclellan's running
against Lincoln and McClellan
politically
is like a status quo guy which we've
talked about and if he wins but probably
just like patch things up and we can
move forward yeah like you know much
easier to figure out we know where
Lincoln is at Lincoln's not stopping no
McClellan we could probably get figure
out some kind of a deal we could make
this thing work yeah you know uh
and Lee Lee so Lee doesn't want to go
down to Vicksburg I mean part of that's
got to be just like hey bro I'm from I'm
from Virginia I don't want to go down to
Pittsburgh I don't want to go all the
way over there right I mean he's he's
from Virginia he from that area he
doesn't want to leave yeah uh I mean and
he's not like a spring chicken either no
well I mean you know uh you know we
talked earlier on the first thing we
kind of like you know hey let's get to
know JD a little bit and I told you like
eight years old you know I mean first
time I go to Lexington Virginia and yeah
that's where the Robert E Lee the tomb
is and that kind of stuff uh in 63 you
know Robert E Lee is 56 years old
now a course like back then like I used
to look at like 56 like tattoos in his
50s man he is so freaking old now
sitting across the table from you today
man like I'm looking at it like Robert E
Lee man who's in the prime of his life
so it's all you know that kind of
perspective of uh but yeah I mean and
and Vicksburg uh you know if if you ever
get a chance to to go down there it's
the second probably the second most
monumented battle Battlefield Military
Park in the United States uh and it's
just amazing uh the Topography of the
terrain uh in and around Vicksburg it's
amazing and what Grant did down there
Grant Stitch and stuff and we could go
on about that forever uh we won't but uh
so he convinces his boss Jefferson Davis
said I'm gonna go North again man you
know now he went North again we covered
you know the Battle of Antietam uh that
took place uh there was a draw
uh now he's gonna he convinces the boss
I'm gonna go do another away game let's
get this out of Virginia maybe we can
help sway that vote coming into 64. we
can give some relief to the folks in
Virginia because if he leaves Virginia
that means that this Army whoever's in
control whether it's hooker me name it
they gotta they gotta do something so
they're gonna have to leave Virginia and
follow me he's assuming uh to be able to
protect Baltimore Washington so okay
yeah it's going to give a relief like
you said now we're in 63 and here we are
again in Virginia and that Second Battle
of Chancellorsville it's Fredericksburg
and chat man that region Spotsylvania
County Stafford County that whole
Culpepper County dude I couldn't imagine
being a citizen living during you know
61-62 time frame man uh it's just got
because you got Union folks there you
got artillery slung around you got a lot
of lead flying horses mules you know
they got intake they got exhaust that's
a lot of horseshit man it's supposed to
be County so they're going to get out
and he's going to do that but this is
the crazy thing man
is he he's going to go three core
and he's going to go do an away game
so he's completely changing the Playbook
man like he's been two core and you know
as he goes north if you looked at it
like us like looking at it like like a
football team
he's 701.
generally generally seven Army of
Northern Virginia that that that one is
Antietam
other than that you know with the if you
look at the peninsula you look up you
know through the battles have been
taking place man Robert E Lee's sitting
around right around you know 701 man and
he's going to go do an away game but
he's got a new playbook of Three core uh
and that now now he can't decide
is it that he can't decide between you
and Hill or is he just thinking you know
what it'd be really nice to have another
maneuver element
like hey well why why
what are the downsides of saying I had
to core
two maneuver elements to move around the
battlefield I'm gonna make three
now I understand that there's
complexities that come with that I
understand that now we got some
relationships that aren't as close but
did he are the forces plused up as well
so now he has that many more a third
more people no no so all he's doing is
basically he's just making smaller core
got it I mean it's not like he's plusing
up to like 200 000. you know what I mean
like it's he's still right around that
same size he's just gonna redistribute
the numbers so it's not like it's you
know I mean he's still got the same
amount of bodies he's just adding a
layer which we kind of talked about that
with that you know when uh remember we
talked Burnside it creates these like
Wayne division commanders and he's just
adding layers so Robert E Lee literally
added a layer you know what I mean and
why why just pick one yeah
you know then you've still got the old
war horse you know these two guys have
both been with Jackson you know what I
mean or pick somebody else you got one
to hold them one to skin them you know
what I mean you got your two core that's
pretty flat and it's worked why are you
gonna go to what that's like you know
you went through the playoffs and then
you're going to the Super Bowl you know
what I mean and you're gonna you're
gonna completely change the way you're
gonna start passing now instead of
running right we made it through the
playoffs running running running running
now we decide we get to the Super Bowl
we're gonna we're gonna start throwing
the ball right and let's bring like
three quarterbacks you know what I mean
and just in case we lose two along the
way yeah I got a third yeah uh you know
so yeah that that's always just kind of
and and to be honest to be honest bro
I'm like I don't know like why why he
did that other than he just didn't have
enough confidence
that either one of those two individuals
could just solely be a core Commander
like because I mean that is a bump you
know what I mean like with any job even
in the military you know you start out
as a team leader you got three dudes you
know what I mean you go to the squad
leader you know to me you got 12 of
these you go to platoon Commander man
you got like 30 of them you know what I
mean and when you first take over even
though it's just like 30 people you're
like 30 people that's a lot of people to
be like you know what I mean but when
you've got 30 people you've got three
Squad leaders uh you know what I mean so
it's not like you're overseeing you're
overseeing three people uh you know what
I mean and that's but that's because you
trust your squad leaders are taking care
of their people well I you know if
you've got Jackson you know what I mean
was he getting these folks ready you
know what I mean for that next step up
uh and I maybe it's got to be that you
know Robert E Lee is assuming that you
know what maybe I should because I mean
I couldn't imagine like taking over 15
000 people yeah and especially when he
when Jackson is such a performer oh and
now you're looking thinking which one of
these two guys gonna fill his shoes
neither the promise is going to leave
them where they're at make them peers
and we'll move forward right right like
you're looking at the guy's a total stud
Jackson's winning battles for you like
like unbelievably
getting the job done and now he's gone
and like oh [__] who am I going to put
in here well you know what neither one
of them will just kind of keep them
neutral and and we'll we'll see how this
works out yeah so that's basically I
mean he's he's you know he's gonna
right wrong or indifferent Robert E Lee
makes the call he's gonna go do an away
game uh and again like you know we're
talking about we finished this out in
May uh and when you know you're reading
about George Gordon Mead man this is
June so like you said man this is a
month and and you know we're in
Spotsylvania Virginia in May
you know when you when when we're
talking about Mead when you read at the
beginning of the book when he gets that
note dude that dude's in Frederick
Maryland
you know what I mean like
because like I I go to Gettysburg like
I've been there a couple of times uh you
know when I leave my house dude it's a
two and a half hour drive
yeah 70 miles an hour yeah I mean these
dudes are walking it's May you know I
mean coming into June East Coast wool
uniforms they got all their stuff you
know what I mean and now they're in
Pursuit so when he gets that note Mead
is already in Frederick Maryland Robert
E Lee has already I mean he's moving up
in so we're in the latter part of June
and Yul is already up like threatening
towards Harrisburg and stuff and and the
route approach remember you know we had
talked in other broadcasts
you know when you when you look at the
army of Northern Virginia they got to
worry about the logistical train just
like they did before when he was going
to go up and they ended up you know with
uh the Lost order and they ended up with
the Battle of Antietam wasn't planned
for uh he's got to run his logs up so
the Bread Basket of the South is still
Shenandoah Valley so he's going to run
that Valley all the way up and then he's
going to cross over into that Cumberland
Valley in Pennsylvania uh so he's that's
going to be his log train so that's how
he's gonna like skirt on the outsides of
DC and not threaten it so he's right
back over there again towards
Shepherdstown uh Virginia Which now that
we get into 1863 something happened in
Virginia now you got this new state
called West Virginia
uh you know what I mean so uh oh they're
not as friendly over there in
Shepherdstown West Virginia uh you know
what I mean they they actually have West
Virginia has Union folks that fight in
Gettysburg what triggered that
uh just you know it's kind of like it's
different like when you cross over yeah
I mean I was born and raised you know I
mean West Virginia Virginia that that
whole Corridor big coal mining uh big
blue collar a lot of work and stuff like
you're not seeing farmlands you're not
seeing plantations you're not seeing
that kind of stuff uh over in the West
Virginia of what we have today it's all
blue collar I mean and it's immigrants
that are moving it because it's mining
it's working river boats you know what I
mean so uh you know they're not
necessarily that Plantation White Collar
you know what I mean old Virginia money
these dudes are like being brought over
to work for that money in the mines and
I mean you could do like a whole staff
ride on just the mining in the
Appalachians uh so they're you know so
they're convinced of like hey man you
guys can like join the union and that's
where you go to like where like Bath
County Virginia is and and Covington
Virginia and then you hit that Allegheny
there and you get into Greenbrier that's
West Virginia so that's that's where
you're starting to hit that that
mountainous region of West Virginia all
the way through Beckley all the way down
uh so those guys are convinced and they
they create a state and they become West
Virginia in 63 and they actually stand
up yeah regiments and that are going to
fight uh you know right up over on
Cemetery Hill is the West Virginia
monuments right there on the cemetery
Hill so that quickly they've already got
folks in action uh fighting for the
Union uh in 63. so that's a another
little change that that kind of takes
place but still so Robert E Lee's going
to start running uh and again it's
almost the same thing when we talked
about an Antietam of where you know with
Antietam hearts and Minds
like when we enter we we go to the away
game man like we're still we're playing
nice with this with the civilian
populace up there man uh and the the
actual the first person like Gettysburg
wasn't even really on the map you know
what I mean like Gettysburg is just like
a small little town but it's got like
seven roads that lead to that town so if
you're going in that area of of
Pennsylvania you're gonna kind of have
to go past Gettysburg and they've got a
rail station you know what I mean it's
prominent roads but it's kind of like on
the way of like Carlisle Harrisburg you
know Chambersburg kind of area but so
it's not necessarily A prominent area
like Harrisburg is
um so Yule is the lead element so as as
he goes north Robert E Lee is going to
lead with General Yule and then he's
gonna move with AP Hill and then
bringing up the rear is going to be
Longstreet uh so you basically got like
uh
if you're if you're looking at them
um you've got second core Jackson's Old
course whose Yule has his new created
third core is AP Hill that's who Robert
E Lee is going to move with and then
Long Street first core his most
competent core Commander
is bringing up the rear
interesting yeah yeah I kind of find
that interesting as as well too uh
because you know we can compare you know
in a little while of who George Gordon
Mead's leading with
uh because he's not using his
you'll find out later he's he doesn't
have Dan sickles up there leading the
charge it's Reynolds uh is the Lead Core
Commander for the army of the Potomac
and and as Yules moving through he's got
to get resupplied and stuff along the
way you know what I mean so he sends
folks into Gettysburg and they're just
there to get shoes and supplies like
literally they're not there to attack do
anything to civilian folks they just but
there's a militia there you know the
little town militia uh you know I mean
they're gonna grab their muskets and
they're like here comes the Confederates
they go out they fire a couple of shots
and they run the hell away because
they're not getting you know this
militia is not going to stand up because
all like the fighting folks from in and
around Pennsylvania they're in the Army
yeah Potomac or they're in the defenses
so nothing against militia people in in
Gettysburg they're just you're not going
to go up against a professional Army
especially not the army of Northern
Virginia 701. uh
so these guys are going to come in and
they're going to report out you know I
mean like every day you got to send
reports to the boss so you'll report
said hey man we got supplies in
Gettysburg we kind of cruised in we had
a you know they had a small militia
because that's going to play a part
later on with another core Commander
because that's information that
everybody knows of like hey like if I
cruise by I'm gonna send folks in maybe
I'm gonna go into Gettysburg the only
threat that's there is militia so that
that's going to play into how we get
into the Battle of Gettysburg a little
bit so
that's kind of Robert E Lee
so uh as this is happening what what's
Mead
what's Mead's goal so they must see this
maneuver happening what is mead what is
it what is the president what's Lincoln
gonna tell me to do yeah so it's the
same thing so one uh you know hey tag
you're it you're the commander uh and
he's got to kind of figure out of like
okay well everybody knows Robert E Lee
is moving North he's he's already in
Pennsylvania
uh and they know this and and I'm sure
that with you know if you look at the
folks that that are in the army of the
Potomac you know we talked about Mead
Pennsylvania Reynolds Pennsylvania
Hancock Pennsylvania I mean they got a
lot of dudes from Pennsylvania and their
families live in Pennsylvania so I'm
sure they're all like yeah dude now it's
our home turf now we're playing tag in
my neighborhood uh you know what I mean
like these people like me now uh and uh
so I'm I'm sure at first they're
thinking yep we're going up there man
we're going to get Robert E Lee out but
he's got a boss
and Abraham Lincoln's biggest concern so
his you know his uh his strategy or in
his vision that he's going to give to
George Gordon Mead is
protect Baltimore and Washington
that's the biggest commander's intent
and the the number one mission for Mead
is you protect Washington DC and you
protect Baltimore yep and what's
interesting about this if you're if
you're listening if you're not too
familiar with the battles
that means
from where from where
the Confederates are they would be
moving south to Baltimore and DC because
they've come up into Pennsylvania
and now they would be moving south
towards DC so so just so you have that
in your head because I know when I first
started reading about this I'd be like
oh
oh they're they're not moving North you
know you think oh the south is going to
move north to attack they're already up
north they're north of DC so now they
would be pushing South so what's what
what does Mead come up with for a plan
uh you know his his thoughts are you
know of course he's looking at the at
the map reconnaissance uh of the air the
good thing is is you know you know like
uh there in Frederick Maryland and that
area I mean folks have been there man
like these guys you know these are
established roads they got people that
are in the organization that kind of
know you know what I mean the the
whereabouts uh and then so he's got to
pick a spot because he doesn't know
again like where's the army of Northern
Virginia going to go are they going to
threaten Baltimore are they going to
threaten D.C because you can't do both
you know what I mean he's not going to
send one core to Baltimore and two core
to DC like he that's not how Robert he
you're always gonna bring the Army
together you're gonna go after one uh so
there there's a creek it's called the
Pipe Creek so he comes up with this Pike
Creek plan uh I think he actually names
it like the Pike Creek circular uh of of
his thoughts processes of of how he's
going to defend Baltimore and Washington
uh and Pipe Creek is down there in that
in that Maryland area on the
Pennsylvania border but it's so that he
can anchor in he's got good anchor his
left is going to be anchored in and his
right anchored in so it's kind of like a
sack and if Robert E Lee turns to the
South making his way to threaten
Baltimore or Washington he's got enough
maneuver space to block so kind of like
how we were talking about on the last
podcast of where Robert E Lee is moving
and blocking to keep him out of Richmond
you know what I mean now he's doing the
same thing but the only difference with
this is which is kind of crazy
is uh dude I mean how do you think the
governor of Pennsylvania is feeling
right now I feel like New Jersey you
know I mean like these dudes and we've
got I mean if anybody wants to I mean
you can literally like you can see all
the email traffic uh of what we would
call today because it's captured in time
and recorded uh you can go back and you
can read some of these letters from
Governors sending to Abraham Lincoln
like hey dude we got nobody here to
defend our home state because we sent
them all for your War brother you know
what I mean you need to get these dudes
the hell out of my [__] State I mean
you know I mean you're paraphor I'm sure
they didn't drop an F-bomb I would have
uh you know what I mean because if I was
the governor of Pennsylvania yeah hey
dude I sent you all my able bodies I've
got women and kids back here man and I
got the army of Northern Virginia and we
all read in the paper what your army did
to Fredericksburg dude you don't think
these guys are going to come back up
yeah you want to like you know blow our
cities to hell and back and loot our
stuff we're in your Turf now you know
what I mean but luckily you know Robert
E Lee's made it very clear dude we're up
here hearts and Minds man we're not
looting you're not looking to get a
bunch of free stuff dude you know I mean
we're up here this is the purpose so
Lincoln's getting pressure
and and I'm sure as an army Commander
he's getting pressure like some of these
politicians man they're just gonna go VR
direct you know to me like hey dude you
need to send somebody up here and get
these people out of here and uh and me
he's gonna go with the boss he's gonna
think of he's going to come up with this
Pipe Creek plan uh and to be able to
protect Baltimore and Washington and
he's hoping he can do a defensive
operation so he's not going to go
offensive and with that he's going to
have Robert E Lee hit him
uh and but he's also learning
he's not you know in this whole thing
we're not going to have any flanks in
the air
what's his anchor points he's got two
stream bets you know what I mean so he's
anchoring it kind of like how he was
anchored in on the Rappahannock yeah so
it's a it's a a I mean it it's good
terrain he's selecting and he has that
time and he also has enough time where
he can call audibles and he's got good
road systems to be able to move so he
can go laterally as well uh yeah Mead
again he's an engineer and the dude is
like Wicked smart so he puts some good
thought into this
uh the only problem is is that you know
he's got you know everybody's is kind of
pursuing up towards the army of Northern
Virginia so he's in Frederick Maryland
but his first core Commander because now
he's in charge his first core Commander
is is Reynolds and Reynolds is also like
a wing Commander so Reynolds has got
he's he's in charge of his core he's
still a core Commander but he's also got
uh oh Howard with 11th core as part of
his wing so he's got Howard following In
Trey so Howard is kind of following
Reynolds when are they maneuvering
towards pipes Creek no is that where
they're going nope they no they they're
not they're not privy yet to the pipes
they're just moving chasing they got to
keep an eye on where the hell is Robert
E Lee going so that they're prepared
uh and and out in the lead of of
Reynolds the lead element of Reynolds is
his cavalry yeah he's got his
reconnaissance yep he's got a uh he's
got a a general uh that's up there and
and he's running reconnaissance to
basically to report the Reynolds of like
he's got eyes on the Confederacy he's
the he's the dude that's reporting back
that's how they know like the progress
of the Confederacy that he's doing his
job uh and the guy that uh that works
for Reynolds uh is an interesting
interesting fellow named John Buford
uh he's the Cavalry commander and he's
running reconnaissance for Reynolds so
we talked a little bit about Calvary but
just just to clarify Cavalry they're the
main purpose of Cavalry is looking on a
horse you can go fast and you can go
fast you can find out what's going on
you can you can then report that
information back up the chain of command
that's what the purpose of Cavalry at
this time is to go out do Recon and and
and so that's what's happening
um
and as so so we already had
Yule pushed up he passed by Gettysburg
sent to people in there for supplies ran
into a little militia no Factor kept
going now we got AP Hill he's now
passing Gettysburg
um and as he's passing Gettysburg that
reconnaissance element from the Union
ran by Beaufort he happens to be in
Gettysburg yep
and he's looking out as AP Hills passing
by Gettysburg
and sees him
um sees you know them and by them I mean
tens of thousands what we got 40 50 000
true troops walking well because yeah
it's it's the Macy's day parade and he's
over in like uh on the Chambersburg Pike
uh so looking over towards that
Cumberland that mountain range that as
you're looking from Gettysburg so yeah
from Gettysburg as you look West yes it
kind of It kind of sinks down the
terrain sinks down and then it rises
back up again just gently it's very
pretty gentle gentle slope down and then
it comes back up and in that sort of
Valley closer to where it comes back up
that's where AP Hill has got his core
walking up yep uh and it's the you know
the modern day that that Chambersburg
Pike uh and yeah and because of the the
like the real so it's basically like
he's got like 15 000 dudes uh it's the
Macy's day parade uh you know what I
mean it's a it's a two-lane two-track
road uh you know I mean it's a prominent
like I said I mean Gettysburg
Pennsylvania may have been there you
know before we were even a country but
it's those rolling Farmland uh of
Pennsylvania that a lot of people are
are very familiar with so AP Hill is is
making his approach up and it's amazing
so is AP Hill hook in a right and now
headed to Gettysburg yeah he's he's his
approach is coming towards Gettysburg
you know I'm sure he needs resupplies
and all that kind of stuff and he's
thinking the same thing you'll did it
you know I mean it's just like if I'm if
I'm ahead of you by a couple of days and
I'm like yeah hey Jocko man hey don't
stop at this gas station man they're out
of this and this gas station's got this
make sure you go to a Wawa and they're
out of Jocko you know what I mean fuel
you need to give them a call real quick
so you know what I mean and it's like
okay yeah that place so you're gonna
take the recommendations of the
reconnaissance that's done before you so
he's like okay well I can head into
Gettysburg I'm gonna so he's making an
approach coming out of Chambersburg and
he's making the approach coming towards
Gettysburg but he's still like you know
he's still like 10 miles out you know
what I mean and but Beaufort gets eyes
on him I mean you're moving that amount
of people man in June that's a lot of
dust there's a lot of animals you know
what I mean that's just you you that's
like trying to hide the Macy's day
parade in the freaking desert man you're
gonna see them from a long ways away and
he's got good eyes on and that's his job
so Beaufort sees this you know the army
of Northern Virginia it doesn't
necessarily know at the time like which
core but he knows that like there's
Folks up threatening up around in
Harrisburg Carlisle area that's just
north of that Chambersburg and north of
Gettysburg so he knows he's got a body
that's up there and then he's got one
that's right here Chambersburg and then
he he doesn't know where Long Street is
nobody's got eyes on Long Street so uh
he he yeah so you got a Buford he sees
this uh and he's got to make decisions
of what he does but like you had said
he's Cavalry and the job of Cavalry is
reconnaissance and if you're in
reconnaissance you literally are told
that you know what I mean you can't do
reconnaissance if you're dead
so don't go getting a gunfight man you
know what I mean just get the
reconnaissance come back and tell us and
let you get in a little Skirmish chance
contact yeah okay take a couple of shots
swing your sword a few times shoot a
shotgun but get the hell out of there
because you can't do Recon if you're
dead so that's his job is to go back and
Report the Reynolds but and at the same
time he's thinking
there's some terrain that I'm sitting on
right now that if they get gonna be a
problem
so at the same time he's thinking hey I
know my job is to run back and and tell
my boss what's going on at the same time
he's thinking wait a second if we just
let these if we let this this Army roll
these Confederates roll in here they're
going to be in a really good spot
and it's going to be a big problem for
us so he's got a little bit of a
decision to make yeah because his boss
Reynolds is about 10 miles east
of Gettysburg coming his way
so you got these two folks and he's
sitting on McPherson's Ridge
so and and as we know like Beaufort made
his way through Gettysburg and he's
doing reconnaissance he's doing map map
updates he's looking at terrain
defensible positions I mean dude
Beaufort is a competent Cavalry
commander man the guy's like been there
done at t-shirts and hats man he is love
the guy as you can kind of tell uh so as
he's coming through town yeah he's just
like you said he's he's up on
McPherson's Ridge and he's like if those
guys get so in Gettysburg you got three
ridgelines right you've got McPherson's
Ridge which is the closest to you know
AP Hills core then you've got the
Seminary McPherson's Ridge is sort of
just what would you say Northwest of the
town of Gettysburg yes so just if you're
trying to picture this in your mind you
got three ridges we're about to talk
about the first one McPherson's Ridge is
the furthest Northwest it's Northwest of
the little town of Gettysburg that's the
first Ridge that we're talking about yep
second Rich second accurate Seminary
Ridge because it has the First Lutheran
Seminary ever established in the United
States it's a prominent building still
there uh if you've seen the movie you'll
see the cupula all that kind of stuff uh
the steeple basically so you got the
Seminary Ridge and they're in between
the McPherson's Ridge and the Seminary
ridges that low kind of farm field that
still is there you know what I mean so
it's got like barley or corn and you
know what I mean that kind of stuff
grows so it's flat Valley and then it's
you know and we've been there multiple
times you know it's not really a big
rise up onto the Seminary but it's
enough to where like that's a you got a
primary line and you got a secondary
line that can support the same Mission
yeah so yeah it's so Seminary and then
eventually you're gonna go you know lose
a little bit of altitude again you're
gonna get to the town of Gettysburg and
then it's is going to go up on the final
Ridge which is Cemetery Ridge Cemetery
and it's pretty easy to find because
there's like a lot of these white stones
up there and it's a freaking Cemetery
right and Cemetery uh and and it's even
more like a lot of folks when you go
there you're like where the hell's the
ridge I mean but the ridge is just like
that I mean it's just enough of a rise
because again between the Seminary and
the cemetery it's another drop down and
you do have the town but south of the
town it's all far open yeah open I mean
and that's and then it's got that slight
little rise and what would you say Jocko
it's like maybe like three quarters of a
mile in between cemetery and Seminary
Ridge and then it's probably less than
that McPherson to Seminary it's like
what maybe a half a mile I mean you're
within range I mean that's that's 308
yeah you know what I mean uh so yeah I
mean so you're looking at the those
three series with a little bitty towel I
mean Gettysburg's not a bang in town no
no even right now it's like a little
tiny Town yeah and at the top at the
North End of cemetery
you've got some other terrain features
as well yep you got uh uh you got a
what's called Cope's Hill so you got
Cemetery Hill where the cemetery is and
then what is that like a little bit like
West like just west of it like I mean
not very far at all man like 90 less
than a mile you've got culps Hill which
is a wood lot uh for the Culp Farm
that's over there on that side
uh then you've got Wolf Hill
uh that's a farther to the East and a
little bit north and you got Benner Hill
you know I mean it's another little
prominent terrain feature but those ones
that are there aren't as like culps Hill
and Cemetery Hill next to the town like
those are the prominent features and
then if you run south down the cemetery
Ridge it's gonna drop down low and the
next thing you know it's going to kick
up and you're gonna gain some elevation
and you're gonna get like back in 63
they just called it the Round Top in
2022 you've got the first little spur is
little round top and then you got a
little draw and then it kicks up to big
round top and that's all a part of
cemetery Rich so if that kind of I mean
I feel like I'm literally there right
now uh you know which yeah love it
uh so that's where buford's at buford's
at that that first Ridge McPherson's
Ridge he's there he's looking he sees AP
Hill uh 15 000 strong that he can kind
of you know the dust the animals like he
sees what's going on he's got a decision
to make what should I do and I'm gonna
go to this book uh by John Buford uh the
book is called John Buford a military
biography written by a guy by the name
of Edward Longacre and so here's what he
says about this decision by early
evening armed with Reliable Reports of
enemy movements in the vicinity Buford
appears to have convinced himself that
he could pull off something never
achieved in this war
a defense in depth by dismounted Cavalry
against a large force of foot soldiers
with full artillery support
of course it would be a risky
proposition his Scouts had informed
Buford that not only would he face a
good portion of Lee's army outside of
Chambersburg and cash down he would also
have to contend with veteran infantry
along roads from Carlisle and York to
oppose these several columns Buford
could place perhaps 2 200 troopers on
the firing line after subtracting hit
from his aggregate Force
the one man in four who would serve as a
horse holdrener tell me about the job of
a horse holder what's going on with that
yeah so uh with the the horse holder
kind of thing is if you if we're in a at
a four-man team
right so they're gonna Dismount they're
gonna fight like dragons like infantry
guys so these guys are gonna like rock
paper scissors from the four of them and
whoever wins they're gonna take all the
horses because that's our Escape Route
like the horses are very important to
the Cavalry and they're going to take
the horses and they're going to go all
the way back over behind Seminary Ridge
and they're gonna hold all four horses
so after I'm like picked to hold the
horses you know Jocko would be looking
at me like JD dude don't don't you
[__] leave with my horse man I don't
care how bad it gets dude you better be
there because I mean it's it's gonna be
game on yeah I mean what he does here is
incredible as a Cavalry commander but
the point of one of the major points
there is we just gave up a quarter of
our fighting yeah a quarter of our guys
just left with the horses taking care of
our extraction platform which is we're
very thankful for but that means JD's
back here you know he's back there over
one one terrain feature away you know
chilling out with some horses we lost
that much of Firepower so here we go
back to the book against such odds
Buford could expect to hold in his
ground for a few hours at Best But Woody
haven't that much time although he was
in contact with Reynolds and knew the
wing Commander would March for
Gettysburg Come Morning Buford could not
say when the nearest Elements of the
army would reach him by refusing to flee
from Lee's path by committing himself to
fight in an advanced position however
favorable he risked not only his
divisions annihilation
but the disarranging of General Mead's
plans which were predicated on a
defensive struggle among the Rolling
Hills of northern Maryland
each of these considerations and others
that came to buford's mind carried its
own argument against doing what he
desired to do
taking a long puff off his pipe he
considered each argument in turn
scrutinizing it from a variety of angles
then he went back over his plan and
matched each of the of its assumptions
with an appropriate set of consequences
for a time he permitted the mixture of
pros and cons to simmer
in the end the strength of the defensive
position he had selected for his army as
well as an irresistible enthusiasm for
calculated risk overpowered whatever
misgivings he might have entertained
before Sundown on the last day in June
Buford had committed himself in thought
and indeed to the greatest challenge of
his career
that challenge being
trying to hold off
fifteen thousand trying to trying to
hold off the the army of Northern
Virginia with two thousand guys yeah and
I mean and you made a a great Point
earlier Jocko when you were talking
about like a force okay so he's got two
thousand so how many you take a quarter
of that
that's not 2 000 anymore you got 500
dudes holding horses
I mean that uh and for Cavalry man to
just go up against infantry because
infantry's bringing artillery with them
you know what I mean like
that it's just uh this is this is
something that you don't necessarily see
every day but you know Beaufort has a
vision
you know what I mean uh
as he rides along and the other thing
that's cool about Beaufort is Beaufort
is 37 years old at this time man I mean
30 he's young uh you know what I mean uh
looking at it of those of course now I
think he's young back when I was a lot
younger I thought he was an old man too
but I look now at 37 like I think it's a
young punk uh you know so he has a
vision because he he knows because he's
so in tune with situational awareness of
what's going on in the army of the
Potomac that all the core spread out
and he knows what the new Commander meat
is slow and methodical he's an engineer
and if if AP Hill and Robert E Lee can
get his core together
and gain these high grounds of
Gettysburg then he's going to roll up
first core then he's going to roll up
11th core you know I mean he's gonna
piece me over these guys because he
understands how fast the ooda loop
of Robert E Lee moves so it's just
incredible that Buford can see this of
what's going to happen to his army and
he's got to make he's got to make a call
and he's got to make a stand he's got to
slow this machine down and buy time for
his commanders yeah and really that
point
of knowing that he look he doesn't have
to necessarily stop them what he's going
to intentionally do is slow them down
and they go like into a into like a
Russian defense right like Hey we're
gonna get out there we're gonna scrap
with you a little bit you start doing
well you start kicking my ass a little
bit cool I'm gonna pull back I'm gonna
pull back to this next little micro
terrain feature I'm gonna pull over this
little over this little Knoll into this
little Ravine uh behind this this stone
wall and they're just gonna harass and
slow down and just retreat
bit by bit but make these guys I mean
dude you're moving we're moving 15 20
000 people like cool you're walking you
know you here's me and JD we're walking
down the road all of a sudden crack
crack we're getting shot at we're
running over we're laying down
somebody's yelling orders to us we're
reloading we took our backpacks off
we're we're fighting we're waiting you
know okay can we get up and move now you
get up oh no we got shot at again
another 15 minutes I'm not moving you
moving I'm not moving okay so you can
see where this is going like that's what
exactly what they do is is uh beaufort's
guys they push out and it's great when
you're on Gettysburg when you're at
Gettysburg when you're on McPherson's
Ridge you can see they kind of push down
down off of McPherson's Ridge a little
bit to start to intercept them early and
that's exactly what they're doing so now
they are able to uh
fight as dragoons which
is awesome and and slow them down now
part of this is Buford and Reynolds too
like they have an outstanding
relationship
um and
Beaufort
sends a note to Reynolds like hey boss
here's what's going on
I got
10 or 20 000 people heading my way I'm
doing my best to slow down get up here
please
yeah exactly uh
you know it because it's it's not like
the Cavalry guys are like gonna dig in
you know what I mean and go like oh yeah
we're gonna hold these folks off it's
exactly what you're talking about you
know like earlier we kind of talked
about like you know if we went home and
said hey you know we tell the wife and
kids let's go get in the car and I mean
we're gonna go out to dinner and it's
gonna take like 15 minutes easy well if
you put like one person outside shooting
at us it's gonna take a hell of a lot
longer than 15 minutes because you're
gonna be trying to get the kids hey go
out and go ahead and start the car like
I'm not going the hell out there man
there's somebody out there shooting at
me you know what I mean and
so that ability again now so he's he's
looking at it you know that that time
distance space and and his relationship
that he has with Reynolds I mean we've
already talked about John Reynolds man I
mean obviously he's very well thought of
If Abraham Lincoln it wants him to run
the army
uh if two you know what I mean a lot of
the folks like the troops love Reynolds
uh you know what I mean I mean he's just
he's a great guy great commander and
then he's got a great relationship with
his reconnaissance officer that's that's
John Buford so these guys have a great
that's his eyes and ears
like you know everything he's a a
directed telescope of the commander
so Reynolds trusts Buford and like I
said and buford's got a I mean in that
book uh written on John Buford uh you
know I mean buford's got time where he
learned this kind of stuff because he
was out west remember like on on future
episodes we talked about how big the
Army was at the beginning of the Civil
War and all those companies were all out
west well he was one of those guys out
west
and he was fighting against the Native
Americans and they learned really
quickly Cavalry and shooting a rifle off
of a horse it doesn't really work out
that well get the hell off the horse man
you know what I mean and and fight like
dragoons so he's gonna bring that kind
of tactic
to Gettysburg uh and then his just
I mean he's a student of the game
to him to be a Cavalry guy and to
understand that defense in depth the
time distance space you know I mean that
is what's just amazing to me with John
Buford uh and then he's going to send
that note back and he also knows because
you know it's a big risk for him like he
doesn't know what Reynolds is going to
do and he also doesn't know what kind of
the rest of the Army's doing like
Beaufort doesn't know that this Pipe
Creek kind of thing's coming out but
Reynolds and the core commanders are
getting word of this you know what I
mean that hey man this is kind of kind
of be I mean they they have to expect
like you get a new Commander he's going
to come out with orders uh and
with that as soon as Reynolds gets that
note
you know what I mean he giddy ups and
starts making his way towards Gettysburg
and again he's got about a 10 miler you
know what I mean well again 10 miles man
and it he's got pretty good roads but
he's going to make his way because he
understands
that he's got 2 000 folks and he's
reporting that there's 15 000 people
heading that way Reynolds is a smart guy
man he can do the math quickly and he's
like if you get here and you can hold
this High Ground man you're gonna lay
the wood to those Confederates coming up
this road so Reynolds is gonna giddy up
and he's going to get his way
he's not stopping at Starbucks to get a
frappa lap a ding dong man he's getting
on the pony and he's riding yeah much
different than you know we we spoke a
lot about McClellan and how McClellan
would exaggerate what was happening
there's this many troops and so like you
get a report from McClellan like hey I
need help I got you know twenty thousand
you're like oh whatever dude he's like
I'm blowing this guy off but when you
have that trust you have that
relationship then it's oh if buford's
telling me that I need to get up there
let's go let's go so that trust up and
down the chain of command and that
relationship up and down the chain of
command is uh is what allows this to be
successful at least this early stage of
the battle Yeah because and even it even
goes farther with that now you're
looking at I mean it's a whole different
Dynamic that we're dealing with here in
the army of the Potomac like when you
brought up like Little Mac and like you
know his I mean if that was him at
McPherson's Rich there's 198 million
people down in Chambersburg you know
what I mean like like the whole old
confederacies moved to Chambersburg you
know with
with these guys so he's going to get
that information from Beaufort so guess
what Reynolds is going to do he's going
to send a freaking teenager man down and
he's going to let the other folks know
he's going to let his boss know because
of his relationship with Mead and
anything coming from Reynolds to Mead
you think he's going to be like oh man
what the hell is Reynolds doing up there
man I got this whole plan I've been
working on I mean you know typical
engineer you know what I mean you know
my dad you know he's got nothing against
Engineers I love him uh but you know
he's like man I'm sure he put a lot of
thought into that freaking plan into
pipes Creek yeah now pipes Creek he's
getting that's kind of get thrown out
the window yeah because now you've also
got these other core commanders that are
down in Maryland
so if you're going to shift from from
down at pipes Creek up to Gettysburg
you're causing a lot of your peer core
commanders they're gonna have to make a
pretty significant move 40 something
miles right so instead of Reynolds going
you know let's say 30 30 40 miles to get
down there now if if they established
this is going to be where go time is now
all of those folks to include the new
Army Commander it's got to come from
Frederick Maryland to Gettysburg so he's
literally putting the entire Army in
motion and all the other his peers have
already seen the Pipe Creek circular so
what do you think they're all doing
getting their folks ready to go to Pike
Creek and then here's John Reynolds
sends a note back and this guy Buford
who's a Cavalry guy is making this call
you know it's just amazing
the relationship between Beaufort to
Reynolds to Mead I mean we're seeing
something that we haven't seen in the
army of the Potomac you also see open
minds you know which we've seen a lot of
closed minds I haven't really used that
term I use it all the time in in when I
work with people and talk about
leadership
we've seen a lot of closed minds I.E
we're at chancellorville I get a report
that the Confederates are moving to my
flank and I go I I don't want to hear
that right there's a lot of these closed
minds but to have an open mind and think
oh the battle is not what I thought it
was going to be
my mind is open what adjustments do we
need to make now we've also talked about
the fact that Lee
likes to pick his Battlefield
he likes to choose where he's going to
fight
and it seems like this is not his at
this point this is not he's not looking
at this as an advantageous place to get
into a scrap
with his hole with his whole Army so
this is a point where he's saying look
you're going to go into Gettysburg okay
there might be some militia in there
okay
but we don't want to fight here we you
know and his orders are
don't get into a general engagement
right that's that's Lee's assessment
that's what Lee he doesn't want to get
into a big fight here he's he he hadn't
chosen this he probably you know maybe
he hasn't gone up there looked at it
himself or he's got some other thing in
mind or he's seeing the vision of where
he wants this battle to take place and
it ain't in Gettysburg so he tells his
guys all right hey you're going to go in
get some stuff don't don't get you might
get some resistance okay but don't get
into a general engagement how's that
work out for him yeah uh in your spot
remember you know these three core are
all separated so he's you know and if
he's going to go into about he's every
battle that we've talked about there's
one thing that's for certain
the union always has more people
than the Confederates like everyone that
we thought we have never talked about
like man Robert E Lee's got him like
three to one like he's never seen those
odds so yeah and he likes to see the
truck Robert E Lee is he's an engineer
as well his he's just got a really cool
loop you know what I mean like the dude
can I mean he can figure [__] out quick
uh that's why a lot of the folks you
know when you when you study Robert E
Lee and and there's you know tons of
stuff written written on Robert E Lee as
well so
uh you know he's got a bunch of teenage
couriers that are hanging out with him
as well so he's you know when they get
up in the morning you know of July 1st
you know what I mean he's got to send a
yellow sticky out to his core commanders
just like he had been doing forever and
and you were spot on man you know he's
gonna send a note out that says do not
get a general engagement
primary reason being well primary reason
being is like hey look eels were up
north yep uh Long Street still down
south like we're we're not we're not
unified and we don't want to fight like
hey I walk into a bar by myself I'm
gonna wait till Echo and JD show up
before I start hitting people right
that's yeah I don't want to get into a
general engagement like I might talk a
little smack but I'm gonna like keep it
cool so that's what he's saying he said
look we're not unified right now
don't get in and and I haven't seen the
terrain I don't know about the terrain
this I haven't decided this is where I
want to fight so he tells everybody on
his yellow stickies Courier send out
don't get into General engagement yeah
and and you can only imagine that that
also with with Robert E Lee you know he
he had his two core and he had his his
defensive mindset of of James Longstreet
and he had his offensive mindset of
Stonewall Jackson
well that's gone
so he's also got two new core commanders
so I could imagine he want he wants to
yeah he wants to keep him in close and I
could imagine on an away game
I think offensive is not something that
he's like he wants to get into a
position to where he can be attacked
because he's always outnumbered his
resupply I mean his resupply man running
all the way back down to the valley I
mean it's like I mean he's got it's like
20 miles man of a log train I mean huge
because he's got to bring all his stuff
with him if you look at the army of the
Potomac of Frederick Maryland and all
that their supplies you know they got
Baltimore and Washington literally to
their Southeast with Road networks so
like their resupply Depot is as good as
it's going to get as good as it's gonna
yeah and and also the road Network comes
right up and in behind
Cemetery in copes Hill so I mean that's
good terrain ideal ideal and and yeah of
course yeah pipes Creek would have been
banging too uh but that's kind of
they're still accomplishing the mission
of the boss
they're just in a different location
protecting Baltimore and Washington and
the trust that he has with those
commanders to select that position for
him is something that's different in the
army of Northern Virginia
yeah you see what I'm kind of yeah I'm
getting at it's like Robert E Lee wants
to pick that that 701 that one is
because Robert E Lee didn't get a chance
to pick uh it was forced upon him so
he's gonna he's gonna send that that
yellow sticky out to all the core
commanders that don't get into General
engagement and again Robert E Lee is
moving on the Chambersburg Pike with AP
Hill
and they're making the approach to
Gettysburg and they don't know that you
know that that's John Buford up there
you know what I mean like they don't
know that because everybody's always
gonna like we might as well just go and
throw this out here on the table right
now man everybody's like oh well they
didn't have Cavalry no they just didn't
have Jeb Stewart
there's there's freaking Cavalry with
the army of Northern Virginia it's just
not Jeb Stewart
so when people are like oh we didn't
have calorie no he had Cavalry he didn't
have Jeb Stewart so they could still
could have done a better job with
reconnaissance yeah they could have been
running reconnaissance just like but you
know and and that could be a downfall of
Robert E Lee I mean he really likes you
know Jeb Stewart but Jeb Stewart man is
you know he's he's off doing like Jeb
Stewart's [__]
which is what he's out riding around
yeah further south yeah he's South and
coming up on the other side I mean he's
notorious for you know doing his right
around the entire Army you know I mean
kind of doing his disrupting logistical
trains you know ripping up rail line
tearing up Bridges cutting uh Telegraph
I mean doing all that stuff that's just
like that that just running around being
an [__] dude he's an [__] man you
know what I mean like and and everybody
just hates it you know what I mean
they're like that son of a [__] because
it's just like anything else you don't
even have to fire a shot you cut the
line and they're all using Telegraph
sir we're not getting a response back
that son of a [__] cut the [__] line
again and that's going to take time yeah
and that's the the most perishable
is time that's the only thing you can't
get back man it's time
so so as this has happened so there's
not real great reconnaissance and you
got you know uh it's actually what is it
Heath at the front of of the push into
Gettysburg Heath is at the front of the
army of Northern Virginia front of the
Confederates Heath is out front and you
know you you you always when we're up
there you always do a pretty good uh you
always do a pretty good reenactment of
you know you know generally and maybe
it's AP Hill and they're kind of riding
on their horses heading to Gettysburg
and like they hear some gunfire you know
like bang bang and they're like ah and
generally he kind of looks over like
what's that well probably just you know
some of those militias they were coming
up against yeah militia and then they
hear bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang
what was that
maybe a little more militia resistance
and then they started hearing cannons
and then they started hearing a lot of a
lot of rifles of bus gets fired and all
of a sudden
start sounding a hell of a lot like a
general engagement uh yeah I mean yeah
when we're up there you know like up on
Oak Hill uh if you're ever up there
because I always I mean you're talking
about Robert E Lee here man I mean now
that Jackson's down like he is the
Confederacy
and you know and and he's writing with
AP Hill and this is AP Heath works for
AP Hill moving uh with the third core uh
and you know and he's probably just I
guess it's just like me you know if I
was if I'm Lee and your APL and I'm
looking over you and I'm like Jocko you
got the sticky right you know yep yes
sir I got the sticky don't get into
general Gage did you pass that on to
your subordinate folks well of course I
did so
those are like that's artillery up there
brother you know what I mean but again
to go back to your point of not running
reconnaissance the last reconnaissance
information that they had in Gettysburg
was it was militia
uh you know what I mean so failing to
run you know I mean you're a core
Commander man come on AP
you know what I mean lead throw some
guys out man get some eyes on before
you're gonna just get on the road and
start hey diddle diddle and you're way
up there man but he's got Heath
and he's making his way up and just like
you said like I mean beaufort's playing
it smart he's got those guys down there
in that Valley like when we stand up
there man by the barn like you can't get
a better view man and then the other
thing is you're standing in the exact
spot of John Buford I would go to
Gettysburg just on that just to do that
I just want to stand in the same spot as
that dude uh and if you want like one or
a while I got like a man crush on him
and stuff like if you get a chance to
watch the movie uh of Gettysburg uh Sam
Elliott plays John Buford and it's in my
opinion if you die and Sam Elliott plays
you in the movie you were a badass
you're good to go no you're good to hook
brother uh you know what I mean so I
mean in my opinion like his balls need
to be carried around in a dump truck for
what he's doing up there on McPherson's
Ridge just my that's just Shady uh love
the guy so here comes Heath and he's
approaching just like you said but down
there that swamp that Creek that's down
there on the bottom you can kind of see
there's houses there now but that was
you know I mean so yeah now they're
going to start taking those shots and
and Heath and the commanders are like
yeah they're not up front and they got
the privates you know what I mean and
these dudes are getting shot at so of
course yeah they're gonna get down and
they're gonna deploy out and they're
gonna start shooting back and then
they're going to be like hey man we got
some resistance up here and I could just
imagine the Commander's going yeah hey
dude it's a militia man get up we'll
just push on and then they they start
pushing and you know that incline uh
coming up uh the McPherson's Ridge
uh it's it's pretty prominent so now
you're going uphill and then when you
hit that Farmland like dude there's
nowhere to hide out there
and you got these dudes that are up
there on that Ridge and they're gonna
start fine and he's got you know Cal
he's got uh the uh uh horse artillery
with him so they got artillery up there
you know I mean not as much as an
infantry but he's got he's got some guns
so now you're getting hit with artillery
and of course not if you have artillery
you got counter artillery so he's gonna
bring up artillery they're gonna start
deploying and and Hill and and Lee are
riding up you know they're like five
miles back dude you can hear that [__]
yeah I mean and I can only imagine like
dude that is a straight up engagement
going on up there
and by the time uh you know when we go
up there on Oak Hill and and it's a
great vantage point to oversee uh
Gettysburg the town uh and you can see
the cemetery Hill from over there
because you're elevated enough above the
town to see it uh you could see culps
Hill from there you can see the wolf
Hills a little bit off into the distance
and this is where Lee ends up this is
where Lee ends up by the time he ends up
and a place
uh that is that is
north of Gettysburg town and and it's
called Oak Hill and like you're
describing right now it's a very good
vantage point to to look at everything
and that's what he's now he's looking
and going well yeah this is a full-on
general engagement we got a battle but
basically a battle going down here
uh I mean it's uh but just to kind of
put people in into like the perspective
of what's happening is like by the time
Robert E Lee gets there because
everybody's like I mean it's not like
he's got a helicopter that can fly him
up there and he could do a quick Buzz
over I mean by the time he gets there
like
the the Confederates they've already
gotten a general officer and and you
like captured like you know what I mean
like yeah
they're McPherson's Ridge they've
already pushed back and now they're in
that that that Valley that you and I
talked about in between Seminary Ridge
and McPherson's rich and you know you'll
agree because we've been up there a
bunch of times when you look down off of
Oak Hill that's a prominent drop and
then it's just straight flat into the
town where now like I mean it's flat
enough to put in a perspective like
Gettysburg College that's their Sports
fields
you know what I mean so you don't play
sports fields on a freaking Hill man
it's flat it's a valley so he he gets up
there and AP Hill and his folks they're
successfully
pushing that first core of John Reynolds
back off of McPherson's Ridge by the
time Robert E Lee gets to Oak Hill
how's Reynolds doing
yeah
yeah unfortunately uh
also by the time Robert E Lee gets down
there
John Reynolds is not the senior
commander on the field anymore
uh he is like literally uh I mean from
from where we stand there at the
McPherson Barn uh on McPherson's Ridge
like I mean what would you say man like
200 yards down in that wood line a
little bit back off of McPherson's Ridge
is you know Reynolds get shot and killed
like like out of the gate for like out
of the gate man uh you know and and I I
always I always kind of you know because
obviously I've spent a lot of time
standing up there and just thinking
about uh John Buford and what he did
that day but I could imagine when he's
up there just like laying the wood and
you got 1500 guys and then you look back
to the East and you got the Seminary and
you see Reynolds making his way up bro
oh yeah I bet he's like son of a [__]
he's here man because now guess what
it's his Rodeo you know what I mean like
he's now the senior commander and
Reynolds is that guy you know he owns it
I mean you want to talk about a guy
that's got extreme ownership one those
two they own it Reynolds isn't coming in
and like dude I can't believe you picked
this spot he's just in it and he is in
the front lines I mean he's on me he's
not sitting back he very well could have
stayed back at the Seminary Ridge right
next to the Seminary and sent folks
forward and observed the battle from
there but you know as well as I if
you're on Seminary you can't see down
over on that with on the uh on the
western slope of McPherson's Rich so he
comes all the way up to McPherson's rich
and there's a flipping gun fight it's a
battle going on
and he takes one and goes straight down
uh and and Reynolds is killed on
McPherson's Ray there's a marker that's
there uh it sits tucked in uh over by
the wood line a little bit you know it
but you know you could see a path going
through it because a lot of people uh
there's a there's a a Reynolds Monument
that's up there on the Chambersburg Pike
of him on his horse that that sits there
as well that's not where he got killed
that's just where his Monument is so you
got to go over to the South and and you
can see where the marker is of where he
actually got killed and as soon as he
goes down man they get him off the field
quickly because they don't want the
troops to see that Reynolds is down
because that's a morale booster General
Reynolds goes down man
who now became the the senior guy on the
on the field
Howard
that's uh that's not a morale booster
a while this is happening we also have
to remember that you'll
is was further up north and now he's
heading south he got word hey this is
what's going on get down here so so you
got Lee gets to Oak Hill you got Yule
heading south to and again Iowa just
just to just to remind everybody
the Confederate forces are moving to the
South to engage because they had swept
up to the north that's why they're
moving south even though it might be
counter-intuitive but but Yules heading
south to to getting the engagement
um as well uh and you got Lee up on up
on Oak Hill
and he's looking at the battlefield and
you know we got these these these ridges
that we're talking about this High
Ground this available High ground and
he's starting to think the same thing
like all right well I'm here
you think at this point he's decided
this is where it's going to be yeah uh
you know what I mean again you know
Robert E Lee man he's a smart guy and
and just so folks know like we were
talking earlier of when he gets to Oak
Hill
and I encourage everybody go to Oak Hill
uh you know you can look across and you
can see the cemetery and culps Hill but
you can also look up to the north at
Carlisle I mean because it's it's it's
flat Farmland there is no major terrain
feature so yeah so you got you'll making
that approach like everybody just like
you said they're all turning towards
Gettysburg uh because it's not like
they're up there just traipsing around
remember what Robert E Lee is trying to
do he's trying to sway the votes man it
doesn't really even matter if he gets
into a battle you know what I mean if if
he can politically put enough pressure
on Folks up there you know what I mean
and and threaten D.C you know I mean he
could force the hand uh of the Union uh
without even a battle so now he's got
these folks moving in and when you're up
there at Oak Hill so he sees the
approach of how Yule is gonna come in
and he's gonna hit Gettysburg
from the north
so you got AP Hill coming from west to
east and now you've got this other core
of second core coming from North to
South that's pretty good geometry and
you're pushing
they have pushed them off McPherson's
Ridge they're pushing them back through
to Seminary Ridge some of them are
starting to make their way through the
town of Gettysburg and they're starting
to that third line is the cemetery Hill
and Cemetery Ridge nobody's going to
Cops Hill because that's behind it
they're just going to the next High
Ground
they're not going to hang out in the
town they're just running through the
town and they're ending up on Cemetery
Hill which is where Howard is hanging
out
and they're watching this unfold so when
Robert E Lee sees that geometry he's
going to call an audible
you know I mean it's kind of like the
quarterback who gets to kind of play
from the coach but he walks out there
and he gets a look he's like huh I don't
like the way the linebackers are looking
here man and he's going to call Omaha
you know what I mean and they're going
to call an audible and and he's a smart
enough guy his ooda Loop's kind of
running he's looking at the math yep
push him here that's going to expose the
right flank of the Union Army and he
knows that it's not the entire Army of
the Potomac like he knows I mean George
Gordon meat at this time is still
literally in Frederick Maryland man and
he's got a couple of core down there
with them so man this is a huge
Advantage for Robert E Lee it's almost
the vision that Buford had
and he's going to do it without
Longstreet
so he's going to send a yellow sticky
down to yule
that tells you all sees the heights
beyond the town
if practical
[Music]
key word in this podcast has been
practicable so
recap you got Yule heading south you got
Lee up on Oak Hill he's looking down he
measures the geometry runs the calculus
he's like I got this here's what we're
going to do we're going to take that
high ground and that I can see that that
General Lee can see you can see that
High Ground back beyond the beyond the
beyond the town so he sends that message
to yule
take seize the heights beyond beyond the
town if practicable now what's really
cool when you go there on the ground we
get to do this you and I have done this
many many times now we stand on Oak Hill
we look and we look at what's what
Heights are beyond the town
then we get in our cars and we drive
down to where Yule is approaching over
Bob barlows over by barlows and
it's a totally different picture
totally totally different picture so you
know when you look at you ever seen
those weird pieces or if you listen to
this right now you ever seen a weird
piece of art where they they take a
bunch of like marbles hanging from the
ceiling and you look at them it just
looks like a Big Blob and then you walk
over to the right and all of a sudden it
looks like a horse
right it's perspective perspective has
changed so that's exactly what happens
here where when Lee's looking up he can
basically see from that perspective on
okay it looks like there's some kind of
a ridge beyond the town that's what it
looks like just a a general rich just
some High Ground you go over to where
ewell's looking at it from what does it
look like from there it's you're looking
down a valley dude there is no High
Ground beyond the town and you know when
you look at a town you're you're kind of
looking at the steeple you know what I
mean because it's still there to this
day I mean like we said I mean it's not
like Gettysburg's a big town and you get
over there like on the Barlow's Knoll
and you're getting that perspective
looking down and you're like dude I'm
looking down a valley and it's not like
uh he doesn't know where Robert E Lee is
sending the message from yeah yeah which
is another thing he's like hey dude I'm
here and this is how I'm looking just a
cardinal direction I'm looking from west
to east at the Town Yule is a smart
enough dude that he could be like okay
he's looking at so there's the town
Bobby's looking he can't call him Bobby
yet they're not that tight uh so he's
looking at it from from west to east I'm
looking at it from north to south
so if I put a map just literally on the
ground and just like draw do a quick
freaking terrain model like grub the
dirt a little bit you can draw the arrow
okay Lee must be here here's the town
this is it there's the heights got it
because his perspective he's going to be
like okay he must be somewhere over
there because he knows he's moving with
AP Hill right but AP Hill dude is like
they're spread out McPherson's Ridge 20
000 People Bridge so he's looking over
and he's like okay just like I explained
before like at the beginning so you you
look over at the Heights and it's like
you can like from there you can barely
pick out like the cemetery yeah but just
because of that angle yeah
you can't see the Round Top like you
know what I mean so you're in defilate
enough to wear that low ground you're in
a valley but you could see copes Hill
you could see Wolf Hill and you can see
better
well that's three yeah
I I'm good with like just none of them
none of them are behind Beyond this town
from your perspective yeah none of them
are if you would have given a freaking
cardinal direction hey seize the heights
south of the town we could at least
worked with it a little like work with
me a little bit man you know it's like
if you set me out to lunch you know what
I mean and it's like hey Jacob there's
three sandwiches on the menu and you're
just like just get me a sandwich and
then I come back but you're like hey get
me one with meat if practical well when
I get there it's not practical to get
meat sandwiched so I come back with like
just like a a veggie little veggie wrap
for you yeah we got problems yeah you're
gonna be pissed so that's the other key
we've talked about this on one of the
earlier podcasts but the word if
practicable the problem with that word
is it there's such a wide range
of perspective on what is practicable
and what is not because look somebody
says oh I can take that hill with you
know no more than 20 casualties that
seems practical to me someone else's
like hey I'm not going to lose one
person trying to take this hill you want
you don't want me to lose any guys do
you someone else is like oh you know
Jackson would be like oh you want me to
take that hill practicable Oh it's
practical I don't care what the cost is
so you'll so to go into what happens
when you so so you'll decide's gonna try
and do something right yeah so you'll is
gonna make the approach you know after a
while they can kind of figure out which
height because that's where all the
union are kind of running to
but then you know when you look at at
culp's Hill
Culp cell is higher in elevation than
Cemetery Hill and remember I said
earlier there's nobody on culp's Hill
you know I mean because like like you
and I have been there like I mean if you
leave Cemetery Hill
you know what I mean it if you're
looking at it on a map you're like oh
that's not very far that Terrain in
between the two man like if you get up
in the morning like before the staff
ride you know I mean go on a walk and
just because you could go right behind a
hotel because the hotel is literally on
Cemetery Hill walk over to copes Hill
you know just walk it with nobody
shooting at you you know what I mean in
daylight you know what I mean it's a
beautiful walk
but I because people love to just they
love they uh let's all just drag out
Yule and let's just you know pounce him
around a little bit because he didn't
take the freaking Hill where are those
guys coming from
Carlisle where had they been they've
been walking from Spotsylvania Virginia
in June all the way up to Harrisburg and
this isn't like you know they're doing a
through hike on the Appalachian Trail
man you know what I mean like these
dudes are in Wool underwear man making
their way around up there and then now
they're gonna push South coming from
Carlisle
and they're going to get resistant so
they're going to go right into I mean
these dudes have got to be tired they're
dragging all their stuff with them and
then you're gonna get there and he's
gonna get to culps Hill but before he
wants to go up the hill he's gonna send
a reconnaissance up there he's not just
gonna commit everybody because what if
somebody's up there and you know as well
as I do man that's a steep little claw
man to get up to Cope's Hill and it's a
wood lot so it's wooded you know now
they are they let the farm animals and
stuff like eat the underbrush and stuff
so it's not like if you go there today
you're gonna see like a lot of
underbrush you could see through the
trees but you can't see well enough
because what's also happening towards
the end of July 1st the sun's starting
to go down and it's gonna be dark soon
well we've remembered what happened the
last time a commander went forward in
the dark
it was only a month ago that's his core
he has now where's Jackson he went out
monkeying around at dark you know I mean
so he's going to send you know I mean
like like a a a a a reconnaissance of a
picket kind of hey you know I mean go on
up there man and take a look and and see
what's up on there even if it's a
company you know what I mean because it
cut me I mean send a company up there
and they're kind of like online and
they're moving slowly up the top of
culp's hill
you know I mean before he's going to do
a full-on commitment and he also as he
looks at it he sends a note back to
Robert E Lee
and he wants to know if like Hey man can
I get like somebody from AP Hill can he
send me like a division over to kind of
like help me out a brigade you know I
mean can I get some of his folks I mean
he is the one that got us in a general
engagement here you know what I mean but
AP Hills kind of spent by this time if
you could imagine I mean he's been in
battle all day McPherson's Ridge all the
way to he's made it all the way to the
Seminary right and he's pushed him all
the way through the town so you know so
he Robert E Lee gets this note from Yule
hey can I get some reinforcements here
man and he goes he basically says I'll
support you with long-range artillery
well dude long-range artillery is not
going to do anything so no no yeah
and Lee has the ability to be like
AAP Center division over sent him over
and you you're going to attach just like
you had seen before Chancellorsville I
mean there was two divisions that were
fighting with second core I mean Lee has
that capability for sure he's what you
would call the dispatcher yeah
now
world are I mean the union is also
looking at culp's Hill luckily and we
got other troops arriving on the
battlefield at this time yep and so what
happens with the Indiana
oh yeah these uh so the Indiana regiment
because you know when uh when you do
that little morning walk up to cope so
you're gonna see this little small
Monument up there for Indiana you're
like huh yeah if you're from Indiana
you're like oh man Indiana's up here
badass well how did they get there is
kind of the interesting story so you
know you've got a logistic train and
then you've got this [__] that's out
riding around trying to disrupt all your
Logistics so you got to take infantry
and you got to put them with the log
train to protect the log train it's an
important job
when you're you lose Logistics you're
done training so this Indiana regiment
is back there and and they're supposed
to be protecting a log train well
they're Infantry
that nobody's thrilled when it because
you're always looking at it like man
Jocko must not like me because he stuck
me with a log train and everybody else
is up there you know Jason and Steve and
them are up there running around
Gettysburg and I can hear the battle
going on and they're going to be telling
stories man and I'm missing out and so
that's what these Indiana dudes are
standing back there and I can imagine
with the colonel and stuff you know they
got like the Privacy [__] sure it would
be nice to get in the fight sir can't
believe you're back here doing this
[__] you know typical private stuff
and the Colonel's like you know he's
kind of listening to it hey man this is
job this is important too finally the
Colonel's like dude we're in they look
at the dudes at the long train you know
what I mean they're just like these are
like contractor folks that are you know
just dragging wagons and [__] you know
what I mean and they're like hey dude
you're on your own we're getting in this
so Indiana leaves the log train and they
don't tell anybody they just freaking
leave and they make their way and of
course you can hear the gun there's a
lot of activity going on you know what I
mean and everybody's up on Cemetery Hill
so these dudes make their way up to
cemetery Hill
and of course you know Howard and any
commander that's up there they just see
they got a fresh Infantry Regiment they
didn't ask them hey how'd you get here
what were you supposed to be doing
they're just like hey you guys Indiana
yeah hey how about go up there and get
up on copes Hill and occupy copes Hill
because that nobody's there yet and it's
higher than them and they need to get
somebody up there but they also got to
worry about what's in front of them so
they got this like they're looking at it
as like hey man folks are starting to
arrive here and so Indiana gets up on to
copes Hill and I mean dude this is like
minutes
so Indiana leaves culps Hill or as you
were leave Cemetery Hill after they've
been told get up there they make their
way down and through the Little Valley
and they make their way up onto culp's
Hill on this woodlock and it's like they
get there like literally like a couple
of minutes before that reconnaissance
efforts being pushed up by you so you
could imagine like these dudes in a
gunfight the privates from Yule and
they're moving up toward I mean they're
going up that hill one who wants to
fight going up that freaking hell man
not me even still to this day
because it's a prominent terrain feature
in Gettysburg the Indiana gets up there
and they're just stoked to be there and
here they get up there on the military
Crest kind of facing to that Northerly
Direction because that's where all the
threats kind of coming from so they get
into position and the next thing you
know man they see bodies moving up
towards culp's Hill and what do they do
they just it's time to you know lay the
wood so they start firing down into
these Confederates that are making their
way up there what do the Confederate
guys do they turn they run their ass
back down the hill and of course they
got officers down there waiting yeah you
know what I mean like hey what what's
going on up there they're shooting at us
how many a hell if I know you want to
know take your ass up there and go look
but it's dark you know what I mean I'm
not going back up there so they report
that
they report to the command Yule of Culp
cells occupied
that now it becomes not practicable
which I mean come on man I mean this
dude's done a lot of movement it's not
like they haven't done anything that day
and yeah I mean and if it's occupied and
you've been there I mean it's different
if you read the book and you kind of oh
[__] if I was there I would have taken
cope still maybe yeah whatever dude you
know what I mean that's a that's a steep
climb uh so
then the bad thing is with the privates
is the kind of look out of this so
when he pulls his folks back off of
culp's Hill and they kind of set up in a
defensive position so you got AP Hills
over there on the Seminary on the
Seminary Ridge and then you kind of over
on the the north to northeast side of
the town you know what I mean towards
like that that area of closer to culps
Hill that's where Yule's gonna set up uh
his folks are going to spread out all
facing you know what I mean South
towards Gettysburg the town and then
towards culps Hill and Cemetery Hill so
that's they're gonna set up there and
then AP Hill is set up over by the
Seminary and they're gonna set up their
lines on the Seminary and that's gonna
pretty much end day one
you got
I mean Reynolds is dead which put Howard
in charge yep
how does Mead feel about that
yeah uh
when Mead gets the word again it gets it
all the way down uh and he's he's down
in Frederick Maryland and then dispatch
comes down letting them know what the
action is because you know these guys
are sending couriers back man all the
time keeping the Commander in the loop
uh so the commander is getting that
stuff back Mead gets it and he's like
man Reynolds is dead first thing he does
is look at this map he's like man who's
a senior guy on the board and they're
like it's General Howard sir
uh oh
so uh
interesting is is uh he's got his second
core down there with him
uh in the second core commander of the
army of Potomac guy by the name General
Hancock
uh and I know we've we've kind of talked
a little bit about Hancock he's a good
dude uh he's a Pennsylvanian as well uh
very very well respected uh even gets I
mean the pure leadership uh in the Army
the Potomac is trains dramatically I
mean you still got a couple of outlier
core commanders that are running around
the army of atomic uh and we'll talk
about later uh but for the most part
like uh you know Mead has got some good
dudes and he's got a really good one uh
you know even though he loses Reynolds
Hancock is is at that level uh he he's
he's Reynolds level uh in my opinion
love the guy uh so he's gonna basically
he's going to turn to Hancock and he's
going to tell Hancock hey dude
relinquish your core
to Gibbon
and make your way to Gettysburg and I
want you to take command of all actions
in Gettysburg
and
Hancock you know uh Hancock knows that
there's a little bit of a dilemma with
this because he's Junior
to Howard
so now you know how's this going to play
out
you know what I mean I'm gonna go up to
Gettysburg and I'm going to tell a
senior officer
that see even though we're both core
commanders you know how it is in the
military man I don't care if you know
what I mean if you you if two marines
are in a room one of them is senior man
you're damn right yeah you know what I
mean 15 minutes like what is it I got
you yeah you know what I mean and it's
just like dude they just lined us up for
promotion by freaking you know by
alphabetical order and you're a b and
I'm a z so you're yep I got promoted 15
seconds before you boot and Howard's the
kind of guy that seems like the person
that would would exercise that kind of
seniority all day oh in my opinion most
definitely yeah Howard is not gonna lie
because
how is that going to look
you know what I mean like so a junior
dude came up and and he just took
command of everything
it's gonna get out everybody's gonna see
it everybody in the Army knows the
seniority and the organization it's not
like it's a secret you know what I mean
like
uh so yeah he sees it it's going to be a
problem but the cool thing about it is
is uh Mead has a letter when he's when
he's designated from Abraham Lincoln to
be the new Army Commander he he's got a
letter from Abraham Lincoln that says
pretty much dude you can promote you can
fire you can put in charge whoever you
see fit
and he's got this letter and he's going
to say hey dude and he tells that to
Hancock dude I got the slutter man
here's the letter I'm allowed to do
whatever the hell I want I don't care
about seniority man you're in charge get
your ass to Gettysburg so he
takes the letter shoves it in his cargo
pocket or his Satchel they didn't have
cargo pocket stuff they missed out a lot
I love a cargo party so you know what I
mean so he puts it in his Satchel uh and
he's gonna start making his way to
Gettysburg and he's going to leave his
core there and but then the core is
gonna so like he's just not going to be
with the movement but you got to look at
like you know Mead and a lot of people
are like why didn't me just like get on
His Pony and go to meet's got a lot of
stuff to do man he had the Pipe Creek
circular he's got to adjust a lot of
logistics
because all the logistics were coming to
support Pipe Creek now in a matter of
hours it's gone from Pipe Creek that's
in Maryland by the way to Gettysburg
that's in Pennsylvania 40 miles yeah I
mean yeah so he's got to make all these
junk you know amateur study tactics
professional study Logistics we finally
have a professional running the army of
the Potomac in my opinion so yeah he's
going to take and why not man let
Hancock or you know let Hancock go do it
he can do it he's just as capable
big badass in my opinion so that's what
he's going to do and Hancock's going to
make his way
uh up to Gettysburg
um and when he gets up there uh Hancock
is gonna get up the cemetery Hill and
and he's going to see General Howard and
he's thinking about like how am I going
to deal with this guy when I get there
you know I mean knowing that this is
just not going to be good but he's got
some time to think I mean it always you
know it seems to me like we never get
enough time to think like I love
personal time to think
uh so he gets this time to think and he
makes his way up and he gets up there to
cemetery Hill because that's where all
the action is coming you know he comes
up over on the from the East side comes
up onto the back but as he's making his
approach man you know what I mean he's
he's he's he's looking at the train you
know what I mean he's he's looking at
everything of how okay yeah we got copes
here we got Cemetery we got this
Cemetery Ridgeline it's running down we
got the the round tops he goes dude this
is this is this is good terrain man
because he's literally coming up the
approach route from Frederick as all the
other assets are going to be making
their way up he's like dude this is good
and they got interior lines so it's what
like uh in the book and still like when
you come out there it's kind of hard to
if you lay a map out in front of you and
you look at culp's Hill to cemetery Hill
and then you look down Cemetery Ridge to
the Round Top it looks like a fish hook
so they're gonna have these interior
lines with resupply that's going to be
protected by this fish hook so
Hancock goes up to Howard he's like
General Howard you know I mean General
Hancock you know how that all you know
you got to get the formality [__] out of
the way real quick he's like damn sir
you've selected some good ground
if you'll allow me I'll go ahead and
like start taking over placing folks in
so he's literally is convincing Howard
that he he selected this ground
and never it's like the Black Belt
Leadership move instead of going up hey
I'm in charge now here's my letter from
Mead you need to stand down he knows
that would be like drama conflict issues
like just just just drama
and instead he just says Hey Hey sir
looks like you're doing a great job
selecting the ground
if you'll allow me I'll start putting
the troops in some spots and it gives
them a little ego massage you know about
what great ground he selected and
you know uh he's like oh yep that sounds
good go ahead go ahead and [__] you go
go ahead and carry on with that right
just that's what they do oh I mean yeah
I mean the the black and you know what I
love about it because this is another
thing that like that I think of when I
when I'm up there and I always think of
of with Hancock Hancock has the best
interest of the private in mind
because he knows that if they get into
this pissing contest up there and he I
mean he doesn't even break out the
freaking letter from Mead like it never
even comes up
because you know Hancock knows what's
Howard gonna do Howard's gonna get one
of these teenage kids he's gonna write a
message okay well how long does it take
to write a freaking message you know
what I mean then he's gonna give this
message to a little freaking teenager
I've been told that I've been related I
want to debate with this and I have this
I am the senior man yeah you gotta wait
for him to go all the way back down in
two hour three hour Courier on a horse
and get with Mead Mead's got to write
something back now the fight's over
crying out loud yeah I mean and who's
suffering the freaking private that's
what I love about Hancock man he's just
like and then he immediately just goes
to work and Howard is just steps off to
the side well of course you know horse
boy get back to you in crevice you know
what I mean he goes and does Howard shed
uh you know what I mean and Hancock goes
to work uh and and then as this is of
course now what's Hancock gonna do he's
sending a note back to his boss man like
yeah dude it's on yep there's a good
this is a good spot brother you know
what I mean and what of course what's me
gonna do okay he's gonna start to get
his way and all the other forces are
going to start to make their way to
Gettysburg
that's awesome so so they're on their
way and you get this again like you're
talking about this fish hook that ends
up the lines of the Union end up looking
like a fish hook the top of it is like
culps Hill Cemetery Hill they kind of
they kind of go east to west and then it
hooks down and then running north to
south all the way down to Little Round
Top is a big chunk of land a couple
miles long and that ends up being this
fishhook shape yeah I get that right
yeah yeah and and for folks to get a
visualize if you take your right hand
and with your you know your pointer
finger and your thumb and you make it in
the shape of a fish hook and then you
kind of look at the knuckle of your
thumb that that that that the first
person yeah that first knuckle that's
kind of like right in there so that
would be like copes Hill yep then you
drop down to where the knuckle of your
pointer finger that would be cemetery
and then your pointer finger that's the
cemetery very rich so that is that's
you're looking at the fish hook and then
the logistics is running in to that to
the fish hook so you've got Road
networks coming in and that's interior
lines I mean look how easy it is to like
move resources around inside that fish
hook yeah now Robert E Lee on the other
side if you look on the outside of the
fish hook over there by that knuckle the
cemetery Hill you got the town and then
Cemetery Ridge is what three quarters of
a mile away yep well that's over to the
Seminary well then you got Yule that's a
you know he's another Mile and he's not
even he's on the other side of the town
man and then when Long Street finally
comes in well he's all the way down on
the southern end of Seminary Ridge so
for them to move people in and around on
those exterior lines man that's a lot of
movement so yeah I mean uh Hancock and
these guys getting getting the cemetery
and and you know you got to look back at
Buford man he saw this man like dude
somebody's got to be able to occupy this
High Ground like if if we don't occupy
this High Ground if Robert E Lee would
have ended up uh and you know up there
on on the cemetery and and would have
gained culp's Hill man
Game Changer but again you know if
Milton Mead hopefully wouldn't have
fought him there and just stayed down by
Pike's Creek pipes Creek and yep sounds
like cool they'll come and get DC I
guess yep that's probably what he would
have done he wouldn't have like thrown
more resources and just like he's not
going to go up there and then just like
throw resources and start attacking to
try to take you know Cemetery Hill it
doesn't mean [__] to him that's not his
he he just has to protect ball you can
stay in Gettysburg all day long brother
as long as you stay out of DC in
Baltimore I'm keeping my job
so that's where we end up uh uh on the
end of day one is you know you got the
The Fish Hook form with the Union troops
the you could say that the Confederate
troops are also in a fish hook it's just
way way way more spread out more
expanded it's like just it's just a
giant arcing arching you know spread out
of troops that they're in yeah a huge
180 man I mean because they're trying to
cover that that entire Frontage I mean
and and and again they don't have as
many people uh and and yeah like you
said uh
you know the first core commander of
James Longstreet for the army of
Northern Virginia he's not even a player
of day one so he's going to show up you
know that night uh coming into
Gettysburg and then Mead is putting the
rest of his army uh and they're all
moving towards Gettysburg so now it's
all like let's all giddy up and let's
see how this is going to go down and the
other cool thing about at the end of day
one
once Mead takes care of all of his like
General stuff and sends notes back to
because he's got his boss he's got to
keep the boss informed he sent his stuff
back to DC uh he's got a he's got a he's
got a little bit of a ride to get to
Gettysburg and it's at night you know
what I mean so it's it's late in the
evening he packs up his camp and he hops
in to a back of a he's gonna jump in the
back of a wagon gonna get the back of a
wagon and he's gonna take a nap on the
way to Gettysburg
because he knows when he gets there it's
game on and I need to be there's nothing
he can do on the ride up so I think
that's that's pretty cool that the
commander he understands like I'm not
going to get rest for the next couple of
days I'm gonna go up against the dude
that's 701. yeah you know what I mean
this isn't the Pipe Creek plan I've lost
John Reynolds you know what I mean like
and and I this is and he knows what's
happened to every Commander before him
like you're going to be out of a job
quickly you're going to lose and then
you're going to get fired yes I mean we
know that there's a certain sequence
that it's not like anything that's like
mind-blowing uh so he he jumps in the
back of an ambulance you know and he uh
he's gonna he's gonna ride up in the
back and he's gonna take a nap
and the other cool thing about meat is
is when he does get the Gettysburg that
evening he gets up there to Culp he is
personally gonna ride the lines and he's
gonna sketch the lines personally
and he's gonna he knows in his mind how
the units are going to arrive the other
core you know I mean so he knows these
other core are going to be approaching
and he wants to know what chunk of life
because he's an engineer he knows you
give me you know me you give me 5 000
people this is how many this is how much
space 5 000 people can take and then I
got another five thousand and I got
another five thousand so he's gonna
literally sketch out at night riding his
lines personally so that when these
folks arrive they're not waiting around
like have you ever gone somewhere and
you're like waiting around waiting to be
told what to do we love that
you know I mean I love when you like
show up somewhere you immediately know
what you're doing hey here's your piece
of terrain here's where you want your
people here's where your uh fields of
fire are you good to go yep good to go
yep I mean everything's already done we
know exactly what we're doing I mean
it's like us we show up here at the
beginning of the week I wouldn't like
standing around waiting monkeying around
like two or three days what the hell
we're doing dude we've been at it like
literally you know what I mean it's been
game on every day you know what I mean
because we know what the [__] we're
doing you know what I mean like we've
got a plan I love that
uh and and that's what Mead does uh
there's a lot uh so me Mead's a good
dude uh and at some point Lee decides
it's on we're gonna fight here oh yeah
like this is where we're gonna do it day
one because at the end of day one and I
I you know we've had a lot of
discussions about this because everybody
always likes to discuss okay so you're
at the end of the day one you got uh the
the Union Army they're over on the the
cemetery Hill uh in the fish hook and
then you've got the army of Northern
Virginia uh the Confederates are over on
the Seminary uh so like
who won day one
yeah well that depends on your
perspective
yeah
you know I mean uh the the Confederates
killed one of the Premier generals you
know killed they pushed they pushed him
back off McPherson pushed him back off
Seminary
and all the way on to cemetery Ridge so
that feels pretty good but that being
said you got you got the union and the
union has now kind of uh aligned
themselves on a really nice prominent
terrain feature
kind of you know I wouldn't I you know
they do they do this thing with the UFC
now where they do they show what the
odds are at the end of each round
they're like oh at the beginning of the
fight you know everyone thinks this
guy's gonna win now at round two after
you saw round one who's winning now
that's kind of what we're doing right
now and it'd be it'd be a hard one I
don't think the I don't think you could
call it any easier right now than you
could before day one because you're like
well I mean they both have some
advantages like we got some momentum
like if I'm in the Confederates I'm like
hey we got some momentum we pushed you
off of two terrain features we killed
some of your leadership
like we we pushed you all the way back
to this last terrain feature
we'll be up tomorrow morning ready to
kick your ass again meanwhile the other
side's like well we did a light nice
defense and depth we took some
casualties but now we've got awesome
reinforcements coming in
and we're in a prominent terrain feature
good luck tomorrow morning yeah and the
only thing that we know is is both
coaches Mead and Lee
they're both the the message they're
sending out to their people is damn
right we won today
you know what I mean we're going to
smoke check them tomorrow and when you
look at Mead
Mead wanted to be in a defensive
position yeah and he's in it I mean he I
mean that's what I mean
you gotta you got to come up to
Gettysburg you know what I mean to to
see it you know what I mean of where
they are uh and the location on there
man and Mead is in a good spot uh but
again I mean
do 30 days ago we were just talking
about like Robert E Lee and Jackson with
like three to one odds and went out 14
miles with a freaking teenager as a
scout and smoke checked him you know
what I mean so don't be thinking he's
over there and so and Mead knows what
he's up against I mean this is Bobby Lee
uh and so you know Robert E Lee is going
to immediately his ooloops gonna go go
into into thought uh of day two and Long
Street arrives uh and long Street's
gonna come into the tent uh and Lee he's
going to want to fight here at
Gettysburg uh and Lee's going to come up
to where his his initial plan is that he
briefs to Long Street and the core
commanders of this is what we're going
to do this tomorrow morning this is what
we're doing
he's gonna have you know basically he's
going to take Hill is going to stay in
position so he's basically you know he's
going to be like the support by fire
position he wants Long Street that
wasn't engaged at all on day one so he's
gonna be pretty fresh he's got some
fresh guy no they did walk there I'm not
going to take anything away from the
hike but they they didn't get in it they
haven't fired around yet so these guys
are fresh and it's his old war horse
so he's going to be the focus of main
effort so if you know on that road when
you're sitting up on the Seminary Road
if you look down behind the Seminary
back towards the West there's that Black
Horse Tavern road that runs back down
there but there's not really good roads
back there but there's enough to where
he can drop down off the military Crest
and then he's gonna head south and then
he's gonna come and cross over of what
is the Emmitsburg Pike Road you know
that Emmitsburg because if you go south
of Gettysburg you run into Emmitsburg
Maryland uh you're literally Gettysburg
is very close to the Maryland line of
Emmitsburg uh
and then he's going to cross over the
Emmitsburg Road and then just like we
talked about how Jackson did on The
Plank Road when we talked about
Chancellor's vote he's going to straddle
that road you know what I mean and he's
gonna push from the south to the north
you know what I mean and and he's gonna
get that extreme Left Flank of the Union
Army uh and
so basically
basically Lee is like hey uh remember
Chancellor's reveal remember what we did
down there we we flanked him and that's
what we're gonna do here you're gonna
kind of we're on this we're on the
cemetery Seminary Ridge just bump back
off the ridge a little bit they won't be
able to see you walk south
Once you walk south far enough hook a
left and you're going to be on the Left
Flank we're going to roll them up just
like we did down at chancellorville
that's that's the essentially what Lee
wants to do yeah I mean that's what and
and Lee sends a reconnaissance you know
what I mean sends a couple of his
Engineers around there prior just to to
get eyes on you know what I mean he
wants to to run a reconnaissance and
Long Street sends some of his guys with
the guys with Lee so he's sending some
of his own folks on this reconnaissance
and they get it around and if you if you
go south off the Seminary and you get on
the on the on the Emmitsburg Pike Road
and you come back up north like you're
coming into Gettysburg uh up there
you're gonna see like it's very
prominent the peach orchard
and when those guys go out and around
and they're they're kind of like
sneaking up they're trying to get they
don't want to get a gunfight they're
doing reconnaissance when they look into
up there on the peach orchard up there
there's like maybe not even a couple
hundred guys
and then they're gonna make their way
back out and around and they're going to
come back over and they're going to tell
Robert E Lee and James Longstreet you
know what I mean and and the Commander's
there that yeah dude there's just
there's just a couple other dudes man
and their flank is kind of in the air
yeah oh it's in the air like we just
rolled up there yeah like dude let's
giddy up and go and Long Street
he has a different vision of what he
thinks they should do
and he tells Robert E Lee tells Bobby
he's like
hey man why don't we just like screw
Gettysburg and let's go south and east
and let's get in between DC and the army
of the Potomac
kind of like what Meade was gonna do so
he's got the same vision as Mead get in
between them we can pick the defensive
ground it's going to force their hand to
come down and hit us man let's not do
this offensive thing let's go down there
and and a lot of people I mean does does
that is that a viable plan
sure
but if you go down there and you
threaten I always look at it there's the
only reason why because you got you know
you got to kind of look at the of like
okay why wouldn't Robert E Lee do that
that makes perfect freaking sense man
well is that going to leave your
Logistics exposed
you go down there man you know what I
mean like if you push in and get in
between that doesn't mean that George
Gordon meat has to come hit you
he could go straight for your legit I
mean your Logistics trained dude like
you're you're not set up
logistically like the army of the
Potomac is your Logistics trains running
back to the Shenandoah Valley of
Virginia man you know what I mean so
logistically he's on borrowed time to be
able to do all this movements where is
he going to get the food where is he
going to get the forage how is he gonna
take you bring the Army together you
know what I mean they're gonna like when
we talked about it on the on the
previous uh podcast about like how many
horses are there if you look at the
fields of Gettysburg if you put all
those horses there 25
000 horses that place is dirt in a day
they're gonna eat every ounce of grass
and you're gonna have dirt there like
there's just not enough to support that
many people I mean you're bringing in
coming into the little town of
Gettysburg now you've got both armies
and they're literally in a six mile
Square radius
and you know and there's 165
000 people there
with their horses
that town can't
support even today like at the 150th
anniversary of Gettysburg that was you
know a few years back dude they had to
redo the bridging they had to like
structurally get ready for the 150th
anniversary because millions of people
were coming to Gettysburg
so they weren't back that like that's
just a lot of people so he's on borrowed
time and Robert E Lee wants to get him
and wants to get him now
and let's just let's get this over with
so he comes up with the plan he lets
Longstreet kind of have his peace with
him in the tent and then he tells James
this is what we're doing and this is
what I want you to do and James
Longstreet leaves the tent because
everybody else of Hill and Yule are like
long streets to focus the main effort so
everybody else is kind of waiting on him
to move so everybody else is standing by
because once he executes this flanking
maneuver from the south
Yule and hail are then gonna also attack
is that right yeah well you'll more or
less going to be that support base you
know what I mean of hitting them because
they're all within artillery range yeah
I mean you've seen like Hills lines or
like right across so they can stay there
but yeah then like then you'll is gonna
start attacking Cope's Hill right uh you
know I mean because that is still the
most prominent terrain fee
to let everybody kind of know when you
go to Colts Hill if you control culps
Hill and Cemetery Hill you control that
road Network at Gettysburg that is why
it is so key
like everybody like wants to go down and
everybody gets up on the round tops
right you know what I mean which is it
is going to come into play later but you
don't control any road networks from The
Round Top when you control the round
tops you just control the Round Top
that's it yeah not much to control there
no so so so so you know we have a big
leadership discussion about the fact
that you know Lee's basically says
you shut up and do what I told you to do
it's basically what he says which if
you're in a leadership position and
that's where it comes to you're probably
not you're probably not doing the right
thing there's probably so you probably
should open your ears a little bit let's
pay listen to what people are saying
it's never a good sign when you have to
tell someone hey I'm the boss you be
quiet you go do what I told you to do
and that's essentially what happens here
and it becomes pretty evident that
there's like resistance from Long Street
with this plan because he doesn't you
know he doesn't suck it up and say hey
Roger that boss got it I'm on board go
and execute he doesn't really do that he
kind of slow rolls
and and pauses and hesitates and instead
of this being like a pretty rapid action
which by the way we know that none of
these actions are that rapid when you
got 30 000 guys you gotta move and if
you're not if you're not making it
happen if you're not hey everyone could
get in here this is what we're doing
that's how we're actually if you're not
doing it if you don't have that sense of
urgency in your freaking voice like as
step number one if people can't hear it
in your voice you're already lagging
right when I go down and say hey this is
the plan guys like already we already
lost 15 minutes from the tone of my
voice so when I go to Hey listen up
gents this is what's happening okay oh I
just gained four minutes right people
understand that so the sense that I get
and I'm kind of I'm kind of making a
caricature out of this of like long
streets
Slow Roll in this thing
I mean how many doesn't Lee have to go
down multiple times like bro what's
going on yeah because I mean you you
know from from uh you know when you're
there at the Virginia Monument where his
headquarters are I mean you can you can
see right down the seminar and when
you're moving like when you're moving 15
000 people it's not like you're hiding
you know what I mean like everybody can
see and he's looking down there because
he knows he's got to drop off the
military Crest backed by a Black Horse
Tavern Road and he's got to make his way
south and Lee's kind of looking down
there like why isn't anybody moving
because you remember 30 days ago when we
were talking about like when you read
with Jackson like was up before
everybody else was already people on the
road and you know what I mean like he's
already got a scout already got Maps man
I mean he's on it yeah and like you said
like long straight and whatever it is
yeah maybe Lee should have been like why
are you not like what am I not
explaining this one did your guys not
get to go over and look in the peach
orchard and there's a couple other dudes
over there man their their flank is in
the air like what what what what why do
you have a problem with that man like
what what's up I mean I get you're my
defense guy I got it you know what I
mean but we need to go off and you can
play both sides of the ball and even
when Long Street goes like hey man why
don't we just go down there and set up a
you know we'll make them attack us he's
like Hey listen bro I get it that would
be cool our Logistics can't handle that
here's why explain it to him so yeah you
know what you're right I didn't really
think of that cool let's go do this
let's get it done let's get over it this
doesn't sound like that happened doesn't
sound like it was good unity of command
behind this thing yeah and and you know
and this is where you're kind of you're
kind of seeing behind the curtain the
command climates kind of taking a little
bit of a change in the army of Northern
Virginia you know on the approach route
701 man dudes are stoked uh now you're
kind of seeing a little bit of friction
uh coming in in the army of Northern
Virginia in that command climate was
just like you said
the command climate can change with just
unless in seconds
you know what I mean of a change of
command and going from one person to the
I mean literally the the Outlook the
tone of the organization I remember on
one of the podcasts you were talking
about when Jackson by himself showed up
and the troops are like hey there's
Jackson we're good to go
now you don't have them anymore you know
those were long streets guys by the way
that was like we're good we got Jackson
just showed up we're good so yeah
there's like uh maybe they're not quite
as confident as they were yeah and and
so he's gonna go back and you know how
that's all gonna kinda it's all gonna
play out with some of the folks of you
know he's got uh you know his his
division commanders of of hood and some
of the folks that are there so they're
gonna see this and and they already know
because you know in a core they're gonna
have discussions before Long Street goes
in the tent Long Street number probably
doing map [__] so they can figure out
like hey when we go in there we want to
have a plan for the boss you know what I
mean like if you're going into the
meeting normally you prep and you're
like okay I'm gonna try to convince the
boss this is what we're gonna do
tomorrow you know what I mean so long
Street's not an idiot man I mean he's a
he's a competent core Commander uh I'm
not taking anything away from him but
then when he gets out and he's not
necessarily you know Lee's not buying in
with the plan so he's gonna walk out and
he's dragging his feet and then he's
gonna yeah if Robert E Lee has to get on
his freaking horse man and come down a
couple of times even one time of like
why aren't you moving yet man because
that reconnaissance effort dude that's
that's old news man
you know so the longer you wait so it
literally is gonna go like all day man
because now again just like you said
you're trying to move that many people
okay 15 000 people you're gonna drop
down you're gonna go south you're going
to get them out you're going to deploy
online you're going to straddle a
freaking Road man that takes hours
at best yeah at best man hours so by the
time he gets out and around and
straddles the road and starts to make
his way like as if he's going to go into
the attack they can you could see the
peach orchard well the peach orchard
doesn't have a couple of hundred folks
in there man there's a couple of
thousand dudes in the peach orchard now
well no [__] it's been six hours man you
know what I mean like so now Robert E
Lee and now he's looking at it like but
that's more than what we were expecting
so now they gotta call an audible so
they now it's not a flank and then now
it's when they're so him and Robert E
Lee are going to come up with this in
Echelon and and two before we jump into
the echelon though how do we end up with
a few thousand people in in the peach
orchard because when we look at this
when we do that we need to get out our
right finger or get our right hand and
we look at this fish hook
each Orchard is not on our index finger
it's not on the fish hook it is
what uh almost a mile pushed out how far
is it how far is the peach orchard
outside of the fishhook three quarters
of them yeah three quarters easy so it
is not part of the fish hook so you end
up with this unit out there that's not
unified with everybody else
tell us about how that happens because
there's a story behind that one oh it's
funny you should ask like what the I
mean they're not out there picking
Peaches I can tell you that and if you
look at it to give that descriptive like
you know when we stand up there like at
the if you stand at the at the North uh
end of little round top where the the
road is that's right there at the base
and you drop down you've got you drop
down and it's that uh the plum run
Valley so you got this Plum run which is
basically a creek uh but it's a low area
and it's always like you know it's kind
of marshy uh and then you kind of come
up and and as you're coming up you've
got this uh there's the wheat field so
now you've got a wheat field
and then you get to the peach orchard so
yeah it's easily three quarters of a
mile all the way up to that Emmitsburg
Road and at the Emmitsburg road that is
where like when they the peach Orchards
up there that's where a couple hundred
now there's a couple of thousand and
you're spot on man like it the peach
orchard is not even anywhere close like
you couldn't screw it up you know I mean
if it's like hey I want you to put your
people here on the cemetery Ridge like
it is not a park you go down through a
valley across a creek up through a wheat
field to get to the peach orchard dude
you were nowhere near the cemetery
freaking rich so Mead has this perfect
line drawn out this perfect fish hook
he's got every position like laid out he
puts these guys in the fish hook then if
the person that's in charge that he puts
in position is this guy named sickles
and like you said sickles because look
in the spot where sickles was at on the
fish hook
when you don't see the big picture it
doesn't feel optimal right because like
you said you're looking a little bit
uphill like there's some better terrain
out there as you look out
so you you can see where if you don't
take the whole plan into consideration
if you don't think about what the guys
on my right what the guys on my left
what the guys two three four units to my
left two three four units to my right if
you don't think about what they're doing
and how my unit plays into this
completing this picture that's where you
run into a problem and that's the
problem that sickles had sickles isn't
thinking about the unity of this whole
line he's just thinking about himself so
what's up with sickles yeah uh you know
like I I believe like every pie every
time we we talk about a general I'm
always like well you know he's a West
Point grad you're like well that that
doesn't seem to be adding up too much
well this time I'm gonna I'm gonna blow
your hair back a bit and Dan sickles is
not a West Point Grant
he's a politician from New York
and he is very well connected
all the way to Stanton you know what I
mean like he's that kind of connected uh
New York City you know Senator you know
I mean even still this day in 2022 man
you know I mean New York Europe I mean
that's that's a big deal man uh but Dan
sickles
uh he's the third core Commander uh in
the army of the Potomac uh and you know
he he becomes a I mean one thing that I
the one thing he's Brave
that you know what I mean like he he's
he he's brave but he doesn't know what
he's doing uh and Dan sickles I mean
he's Brave and stupid is not a great
yeah combo no especially when you're in
charge look you get a nug that's Brave
and stupid bro that right that guy might
be getting a silver star or a Navy Cross
or something that this that's just how
it might go down you get someone that's
in charge and they're Brave and they're
stupid we could get a bunch of people
killed right so he he gets that section
of the line and Jocko you were spot on I
mean if you're standing there like where
he was like kind of supposed to be on
the cemetery but he doesn't he doesn't
understand the big picture he doesn't
care the big I mean he's legally insane
like legally and that happened uh you
know so Dan sickles you know he's uh
what is he's 43 in Gettysburg uh and
he's got a wife and and she's like 16.
well Dan sickles being the politician
that he is uh you know he has a stable
of women that he kind of has on the side
to include his wife
and his wife doesn't necessarily care
much that her husband is keeping a
stable of women on the side
so while he's off you know what I mean
doing his stuff and she's and they're
living right there in DC you know I mean
he's yeah for the center see they're in
DC she decides to get a boyfriend
well then when like Dan sickles finds
out about this boyfriend he's pissed
well
uh you know when I say the last name of
like back in those days like keys
like have you ever heard of that song
The Star-Spangled Banner written by that
dude keys well uh this is Keys son
that's having an affair with sickle's
wife so sickles is literally going to
call the dude out at Lafayette Park
right across from the White House in
Washington DC to a duel and he's going
to shoot this dude multiple times and
kill him right in front I mean in DC and
and Stanton is going to defend him and
sickles is going to be the first person
in American history to get off on a
temporary insanity plea
so this dude is uh and and you're kind
of like you're staring at me like right
now like every time whenever you hear
the story because you can't just make
this stuff up man it's just like crazy
stuff and you're like well how the hell
did this guy become a general I thought
you had to be like a a West Point grad
well yes
but if you can recruit a lot of people
to come in they're gonna give you rank
for it we even still do it today in the
military you send me home on like
recruiter's assistant you know what I
mean they're like hey JD if you can if
you can convince two of your buddies
join the Marine Corps we're gonna make
you E3 and I'm like really yeah badass
so I'm gonna [__] these guys to get
them in because I can't wait to be a
lance corporal I'm going to be in charge
of [__] you know what I mean well this
here man like if you recruit 10 000
people dude we're gonna make you a
freaking General
well so how does he recruit how those
people well if you're a senator and
you're in New York City he's just going
to shut down all the firehouses and he's
going to put all the firemen and put him
into the army
and Bam I'm a general and that's exactly
what he did yeah
so up there right outside of the peach
orchard there's actually a super cool
New York monument and it's a monument it
has a a an f a a fire fireman and he's
standing next to a soldier you know what
I mean it's right there up there uh by
the peach orchard uh and it's just it's
showing that you know one because when
some of them are like well hey dude like
the the folks in in fire both Wildland
fire structure fire you know what I mean
the Brotherhood inside that man it's
just huge and it's no different in 1860.
I mean those guys that are in the
firehouse man they they are just uh
phenomenal human beings and it's like
okay if one goes dude we're all going so
they all come uh and but that's how uh
sickles
and when he goes into the into the peach
orchard it's not like he's like in any
kind of like defense he he forms this
Salient which is a Salient is like a V
M so if you're in this v formation if if
I if if orientated if you're looking at
the peach orchard so you're he's
basically the pointy end of the V is is
basically facing west
and then you've got the left side of the
V well that's where Longstreet and those
guys are coming up from the south
the north side of the V can't shoot over
at anybody coming up from the south
because you're literally shooting
through your own people so you've
basically taken out half of your Force
then man he's trying to cover such a
large area with his core that he doesn't
have enough people so he's got gaps in
his line so here's how genius this guy
is he's going to fill the gaps with
artillery
now artillery you know they've got a
different job than infantry like they
kind of like this is a big piece of gear
uh and it takes more than one person to
operate it you know what I mean so you
got this this artillery crew you know
what I mean and they're kind of focusing
on the gun
they don't they can't focus to see who's
coming at them so normally you have
infantry supporting the artillery to
protect the artillery I mean even
artillery back there even in still to
this day I mean artillery is considered
the King of the battle
you know I mean I mean it's a uh so you
have artillery unsupported by Infantry
dude that is a that's a huge mistake
because these guys are trying to like
load the gun aim the gun fire the gun
reload the gun and oh by the way this
gun when you fire it it's not like on TV
that piece of artillery jumps about 10
to 12 feet back when they pull the
lanyard dude this thing is jumping
you talk about something that you weigh
in tons jumping 12 feet back so it's a
dangerous job you know what I mean just
within itself of of being in the
artillery back then and and they're not
carrying rifles
they don't get a rifle because their job
is working the gun that's why you put
infantry with them so sickles is also
going to have artillery filling in gaps
and they're unsupported by infantry it's
just I mean just incredible uh of what
what sickles does and the bad thing
about it is
people find you're always under
observation so as soon as sickle starts
making his way out to the peach orchard
word's gonna get back to George Gordon
meat
you know George Gordon Mead
is gonna send people out there he's
gonna tell sickles six times
to get his people back on the cemetery
Ridge
six times
I don't know if everybody heard that six
times he's gonna tell this is an army
Commander telling a Corps Commander get
your people and this is before they're
not in battle yet you know what I mean
like nobody's hit him yet he's told him
George Gordon meat has his son that it's
there and working on his staff his his
son goes out and everybody knows it's
George Gordon Lieutenant made you know
what I mean he comes out you know sir
General you need to get back to the
Seminary yep whatever you know what I
mean he's legally insane do whatever the
hell I want it finally takes George
Gordon Mead who probably has some other
stuff to do now personally has to leave
his headquarters and make his way all so
you remember where his headquarters he's
over there closer to the cemetery Hill
so he's kind of like and he's close to
the line I mean he's like right up on
the line he's like 100 yards or
something oh dude yeah Hunter lies right
on the military Crest and he's gonna get
on his horse and he's gonna ride all the
way down Cemetery Ridge and out to the
peach orchard where he's going to meet
with uh with this guy sickles and he's
gonna like tell sickles and sickles kind
of sees him coming he's like oh [__]
really the boss is here so he's like
looking at me and he's kind of like okay
yeah hey I'll get him and it was almost
like on cue Mead looked at him and said
I don't think they're gonna let you and
here comes the Confederates and they've
caught him all out there in a Salient in
the peach orchard in the wheat field
spread out gaps and it's just not going
to go good
uh
yeah unsupported you know we always talk
about cover Move like these guys got
themselves and just well they couldn't
even cover for themselves like you said
they'd cut off their own firing they
couldn't support each other they weren't
supported by the rest of the line it's
just a complete complete nightmare
um
those guns you got kind of a badass with
those guns Bigelow
oh yeah
one of my favorite uh stories is the
retreat by prolange right talk me
through that what Bigelow has to do
because he's got these guns that weigh
several tons
they're getting pushed on hard it's not
like they got time to you know hitch
horses back up and turn them around and
Tow them out of there while while
totally unsupported by infantry so he
takes another method yeah and and you
know we still do them to this day man
gun drills yeah machine Gunners do it
artillery does it mortars guys do it I
mean they they operate gun drills uh and
if you see a good gun crew you know what
I mean do it's like it's theater man
like I mean that [__] could be on
Broadway yeah I mean I were talking the
other day like the first time I saw
Marine Corps mortar team I was like hmm
I could watch this for a while on a
video this this is what professionalism
looks like yeah I mean it's and I'm
terrible at it you know what I mean like
I'm just 0311 Rifleman yeah I I can pull
a bolt to the rear and put it back
that's that's my capabilities the
mortarman next level like artillery guys
man next level with these gun drills
well you know how like
not every gun crew is the same
because they all have their own leader
that's in charge of that gun crew and uh
and and some some gun Crews man like
Bigelow is that kind of a of a crew
leader that he is constantly drilling
the basics like just repetition to where
like you said like when we were chit
chatting the other day man about the
mortamin I told you like with Eric
Carlson he's probably the best mortar
man I've ever seen like like it's and I
can't do Eric Carlson there's no way
he's just that good that's Bigelow man
he's just that and he's just repetition
with the crew and of course the crew's
kind of like they're looking at the
other Crews like man those dudes are
sitting in the shade man they're like
you know drinking Yoo-hoos having a good
time and here we're over here man just
constantly doing my Bigelow is such an
[__] man but when Bigelow's preparing
them for this moment
because everybody knows that Bigelow
runs the best gun crew and you know when
we talk about like this prolange uh to
try to like it's a leather strap like if
if you've got and everybody who has seen
this
if if you've got a vehicle and you're
towing a camper
right you've got this this hitch that
goes on to the ball right two inch three
inch whatever you got the hitch but then
you also you get these chains that you
can then hook in and that's like the
secondary way to move it that's not the
primary way
but do you ever practice towing with
just the chains no well Bigelow does
you know what I mean so that's the pro
launch of the piece of artillery it's
this leather strap you know what I mean
so he so these guys know how to to
operate using the pro launch so
literally as everybody because maid has
to make a decision he he can't leave
sickles's core out there just to hang to
dry so he immediately goes back
and oh by the way his horse gets spooked
and he gets like rode off for a little
while you know just you know when shit's
going wrong like it seems like
everything starts to go wrong
so Mead
on his way back he's got to start
pulling resources because now they're
they're getting attacked it's long
Street's core you know what I mean
sickles is not where he's supposed to be
nothing's happening yet over at you know
Cemetery Hill and Culp cell because
remember everything's going off of the
focus of main effort and they're going
to do this echelon
so
he's going to have to start pulling
resources to get sickles out of the
peach orchard and back to the cemetery
huge I mean and as if George Gordon meat
has nothing better to do well when this
is all kind of happening
they're pulling the folks back and they
look at Bigelow and they're like hey
dude you're gonna have to hold these
folks off while the rest of us get out
so and when you go there and you know
we've we've been there and and you're
looking back across the field uh heading
towards the uh the cemetery Ridge he's
literally going to
hold off the Confederate infantry and
he's going to start jumping his
artillery guns 10 to 12 feet at a time
all the way back across the field you
know what I mean while still fire like
you know I mean like with artillery
I mean it's just it's incredible
uh so that's that's uh that's Bigelow uh
you you started to go into it before I
kind of cut you off and and asked you
about Bigelow the ash of the new Echelon
plan that's come about
yeah so when you when you say like
actually it's all French terms man
everybody's out running around with
French textbooks trying to figure out
what they're supposed to be doing you
know what I mean so they're going for
the last guy you know what I mean of
it's the Napoleon uh so this is this in
Echelon so to cut it so probably pretty
much just everybody you know in America
even if you don't like it you've
probably watched a football game once in
your life so it's basically they're
gonna try to pull off a draw play
on a massive scale
so meeting with that is they're going to
attack with a a four o'clock attack and
then a five o'clock attack and then
what's this doing is it's drawing the
resources down so that when you get a
six o'clock attack there's not enough
resources in the line and you break
through the lines does that kind of make
sense so and Long Street because because
they can't just not just a regular flank
anymore right because there's too many
people in the peach orchard so that
thing is out the window so now they're
like all right that's not going to work
out a regular flank's not gonna work out
so this is the beginning of an echelon
attack you're the four o'clock attack
Long Street you're the four o'clock
attack you're the initial assault that's
going to start drawing Union forces down
then we're gonna hit him with the next
guy up at five o'clock that's gonna draw
even more people down at six o'clock
hopefully so many people are drawn down
that we can get through and we'll keep
doing that all the way up you know the
the Confederate lines yeah because not
not only are they changing the game plan
on the southern end of the battlefield
he's also got to send the note up to Yul
so he's basically doing two draw plays
one at the South End four five and six
and then yours gonna do seven eight nine
to be able to draw again because dude
they still want copes Hill so he's gonna
have you know what I mean a six o'clock
a seven o'clock and you know all the way
through so you kind of kind of get these
these draw plays the problem is and
they're going to use like divisions with
their brigades you know what I mean so
these have drawn them out it's this huge
draw play getting everybody to one side
of the field and then you're just gonna
scoot right around the other side with a
little bit of resistance you know what I
mean you're gonna get a touchdown so it
makes sense right but they're calling it
on the Fly and the other kind of problem
of it is is
uh yeah like I said this is the wheels
are coming off the cart man because
you're like okay well if they're doing
this Echelon how the hell did we end up
over on the Round Top well that's
because when that first four o'clock
attack decides yeah I'm not going to the
peach the peach orchard I'm going to the
round tops he just disobeyed order so
instead of going north he just turns
East and heads towards the round tops he
sees who's that it's hood hood hood sees
the round tops and they're nice looking
terrain especially when you look at them
from that far to the West because when
you look at them that farther west it
looks like you just got a nice flat kind
of run up to him that you can get up on
this High Ground yeah it looks like
because it's a wheat field so you see
the peach orchard to the wheat field and
you and I we we talked about the plum
run and we talked about that Marsh area
but we left one little key terrain
feature that's down that you can't see
from up there no
and that's what we call Devil's Den
now Devil's Den
when you get to see Devil's Den
like and you're up there and you drive
down those Boulders and stuff I mean
it's just amazing and it didn't get the
name Devil's Den from the battle that's
what the town folk called Devil's dead
Devil's Den was like one of those Harry
that was like snakes and stuff and
that's where the devil hung out so I
always kind of look at it as like
you know when you're a teenager you know
what I mean you want to like you know
you want to go on a date you're going to
go park out of Devil's dad because it's
out of town you know what I mean you got
these cool rocks I look at it like if
you created
like a like a video game Battlefield
where you're just gonna have
like obstacles and rocks and just weird
looking cool stuff that you'd want to
run around in a video game you'd make
devil's done that's what it looks like
yeah oh yeah most definitely but you
don't want it
the round tops
you know what I mean
formation of rock like a spine that just
comes up out to where now you've got
this rock formation and then you've got
the plum run and then you gotta go
uphill to get to Little Round Top so
we'll basically be talking about because
you know in the books and a lot of the
readings they just call them the round
tops but when you're there there's a
definite difference between loot around
top and big round top uh and the rock
formations when you look at the front of
little round top are pretty prominent
yeah uh up there you set granite rock uh
formation that's up there
and when he goes for that round I'm not
going to doubt anybody that it is it's
good high ground I mean I mean little
round top but the problem is is like a
lot of people mistake it because there's
this nice road now that gets up there
the only actual Road like you couldn't
Farm the round top so just like corpse
Hill the round tops you're using that
stuff as like wood Lots so there's on
the on the East back side there's a way
to get up but it's just like a Logging
Road to get up there to access so this
is not going to be an easy feat for the
Confederacy to get through Devil's Den
plus like you know you've got that that
Salient that they created you know I
mean so you got folks so this is where
in the readings in the books man this is
where you're gonna get in to the peach
orchard and the wheat field and Devil's
Den and it's like you're just like
orbiting this giant hairball man I mean
it's just a conglomeration man of like
this Things Are not going well for both
sides of the armies
and and as they they start approaching
like when you look at the wheat field
you know and if we want to talk about
like the the wheat field the amount of
of just utter destruction in the wheat
field it was said that the wheat field
you couldn't walk across the wheat field
without stepping on a body
I mean that's the type of Carnage yeah
and the wheat field is Big yeah you know
the wheat field is probably five or
maybe
I mean maybe 10 football fields across
maybe it's like a thousand yards but I
mean it's a big chunk of land yeah it's
a big chocolate land man yeah and
there's a and I mean and it's because
now people are just starting to disobey
orders man they're just not doing what
they're told I mean you know you start
off with sickles yeah you know I mean
just not doing just blatantly just not
doing what he's told how hard is it
Cemetery Rich got it put your line there
because if he would have been where he
was supposed to be like literally when
Long Street tried to do this flank
attack and if they would have gone
through the peach orchard and there
would just been like a few dudes there
they literally would have exposed their
entire right flank to the cemetery Ridge
because it's deceiving looking from
Seminary Ridge over to cemetery Ridge
it's deceiving there you know what I
mean there you don't see the wheat field
you don't see Devil's Den you don't see
Plum run you can't see any of that so
Liam them are just assuming that that
Cemetery Ridge is right up there next to
the peach orchard they're assuming that
but it's actually back three quarters
which no offense I mean there's a lot of
stuff that you just can't see you're
just you make a call and you go do it so
these guys are doing this so that's how
we end up to where
at that point in time
uh it's almost like what's taking place
on day one up on copes Hill there's
nobody up there nobody up on the rounds
on the round top round Top's prominent
terrain feature at the South End of the
Union line is these prominent terrain
features and there's no one on them yeah
because he doesn't have enough bodies
you know what I mean yet to come in to
occupy all of it you know what I mean
and again if you control the Round Top
like you said you just control the Round
Top you don't control the road Network
you know what I mean so Mead it's more
important controlling copes Hill
Cemetery Hill and that road network but
he still has to worry about you don't
want to give that up because now you're
going to lose a lot right there uh at
the edge so
there it is occupied and it's occupied
by a guy by the name of Governor Warren
occupied by one dude yeah one dude and
he's got his signalman with him so he's
got some dude with flags two dudes yeah
he's got two dudes with flags uh so
Warren like when you get up there uh up
onto the little round top and you know
they got that cool little statue of
Warren standing up there he's a he's a
chappy looking fellow you know what I
mean he's got his little by nose and
stuff and he's standing up there on the
Rock but that's a great Viewpoint of the
entire South End of the battlefield man
you can see over Devil's Den you can see
down into the wheat field you can see up
to the peach orchard so I mean you've
got a great Viewpoint so and and he's
the chief engineer and he's a good
friend of George Jordan Mead so he's a
directed telescope for Mead and he's up
there because they use the wig wag
signal you know I mean kind of stuff so
it's just like baseball uh you know what
I mean they're doing signals and and uh
and everybody's always trying to figure
out each other's signals you know I mean
they could have done a Houston Astros
and beat on some [__] cans or something
whatever it takes to win you know what I
mean like okay so he gets that so he's
going to do whatever it takes to win and
he stand up there and he's like dude he
could see hood and these guys coming I
mean it's very blatant you can just see
it so he sees this and he looks at his
signal guys and he's like hey dude just
start waving your flags like there's a
lot of [__] going on
and the dudes are like so he doesn't
really mean nipped I don't care it just
start waving flags so they start waving
flags well
if they can see the Confederates then
the Confederates can see them up there
and especially if you're standing on a
little round top waving flags
everybody's gonna see you but if they
see you waving flags you're kind of like
hey boss Jocko do you see that [__]
they're waving the [__] out of those
flags what do they mean JD I I don't
know but it must be something because
they're waving them a lot and at that
time then you know so he's got a yacht
he gets a sticky out talking about
Governor Warren uh he's gonna send a
note back to Mead so he sends a note
with a courier back to me basically
saying we need to get some bodies up
here on a little round top man like now
like these guys are coming you need to
get bodies and of course like we said
Mead's got other stuff going on as well
but he trusts Warren
and when he sees that note he sends it
over because he's sending resources of
some of the other core that are coming
in because he's sending folks into the
wheat field and into the peach orchard
to get sickles back you know what I mean
this is like that that rescue effort to
get sickles and third core back so
he sends a note and as the note if you
could always imagine like you got this
this teenager riding around on a pony
and he's looking for a general officer
so he's looking for this General officer
and he can't and this dude by the name
of of strong Vincent
who's the Brigade guy sees this guy
riding around he's got this note and
he's Vincent strong Vincent is supposed
to be taking his folks with his Brigade
they're supposed to be heading over to
the wheat field right so on his way to
the Wheatfield but he sees his kid come
by and he's like hey dude give me that
note and he sees the note and it's and
he reads it and he's like this is from
Mead Mead's approval we need to get
bodies up onto the Round Top like now so
he makes a decision without anybody else
and he's going to take his folks and
he's going to take him up and around and
strong Vincent is now going to occupy
the Round Top little round top and he's
going to bring him up in behind so that
he's not exposing them on the front so
he takes him on that Eastern Slope and
he brings him up onto the approach of
little round top and it just takes
action now
uh that you know so again
he's supposed to be in the wheat field
because this is gonna this is gonna have
a little bit of effect later on he's
supposed to be in the wheat field but he
ends up going up and occupying he just
takes action
and he goes up and and he's going to
occupy a little round top yeah and you
know we talk about like what this effort
what it's like walking
and um going going back just to hear a
first person account going back to
Elijah hunt Rhodes again for uh from all
for the Union
and he's he's rolling in I mean these
guys you guys are living through
campaign and battle after battle here he
is
rolling in to Gettysburg he says this on
the night of July 1st we were in camp
near Manchester Maryland rumors of
fighting in Pennsylvania have been heard
all the days but the distance was so
great to the battlefield that we knew
little about it the men were tired and
hungry and laid down to rest early in
the evening at nine o'clock orders came
for us to move and we in great haste
packed up and started on the road
towards Pennsylvania General hooker had
has been relieved and General George G
Mead of Pennsylvania assigned to command
the army of the Potomac what does it all
mean
well it is none of our Affairs and we
obey orders and March out into the road
we struggle on through the night
the men almost dead for lack of sleep
and falling over their own Shadows but
still we go on in the warm summer night
little is said by anyone for we are all
too weary to talk only now and then an
officers sharply orders the men to close
up
sometimes the column would halt for a
moment as obstructions were met in the
advance and then we would run to catch
up
daylight brought no Halt and what little
hard bread we had was taken from the
haversacks and eaten on as we marched
on the morning of July 2nd we heard the
firing in the front and then we
understood the reason for such great
haste I was taken sick upon the road and
fell helpless to the ground
the surgeon Dr Carr gave me a remedy and
a pass for admittance to an ambulance
I lay upon the roadside until several
regiments had passed when I began to
revive I immediately hurried on and soon
came up with my company B
the boys received me well and I went on
without further trouble
the firing in our front grew loud and
more distinct and soon we met the poor
wounded fellows being carried to the
rear
at a place called Littlestown we saw
large numbers of our wounded men and all
kinds of carriages were being used to
take them to the hospitals at about two
o'clock
P.M we reached the battlefield of
Gettysburg Pennsylvania having made a
March of 34 miles without a halt
the men threw themselves upon the ground
exhausted
but were soon ordered forward we
followed the road blocked with troops
and trains until 4 pm when the field of
battle with the long lines of struggling
weary soldiers burst upon us with loud
cheers the old sixth Corps took up and
double quick and were soon in the line
of battle near the left of the main line
held by the fifth Corps the fifth Corps
were in reserve but as soon as we took
their place they moved forward and took
part in the fight our division was
finally sent to the front and relieved
General skyke's division of regulars
Pickett firing was kept up until long
after dark when we were relieved and
returned to short distance
[Music]
the men threw themselves upon the ground
and oblivious to the dead and dying
around us we slept the sleep of the
weary
so that's what these guys that's what
that's what this is like that's what
these guys are going through
um
as they as they go into battle
and as you said you got strong Vincent
he's moved he he takes the initiative
to go and
take the round tops take little round
top which is the one that they can take
he's assigned to him as the 20th main
under Joshua Lawrence Chamberlain and
he's assigned by Vincent to hold the
Left Flank
and we need to go to Chamberlain himself
to hear
what that was like for him so here we go
with Chamberlain
and he says this
passing to the Southern Slope of little
round top Colonel Vincent indicated to
me the ground my regiment was to occupy
informing me that this was the extreme
Left Flank of our general line and that
A desperate attack was expected in order
to turn that position concluding by
telling me that I was to hold that
ground at all hazards
this was the last word I heard from him
my line formed I immediately detached
Company B Captain Morrell commanding to
extend from my Left Flank across this
hollow as a line of skirmishers with
directions to act as occasion might
dictate to prevent a surprise on my
exposed flank and rear in the midst of
this an officer from my Center informed
me that some important movement of the
enemy was going on in his front beyond
that line beyond that of a line with
which we were engaged
mounting a large Rock I was able to see
a considerable body of the enemy moving
by the flank in the rear of their line
engaged and passing from the direction
of the foot of the great Round Top
through the valley toward the front of
my left
we opened a Brisk fire at close range
which was so sudden and effective that
they soon fell back among the rocks and
low trees in the valley only to burst
forth again with a shout
and rapidly Advanced firing as they came
they pushed up to within a dozen yards
of us
before the terrible effectiveness of our
fire compelled them to break and take
shelter
they renewed The Assault on our whole
front and for an hour the fighting was
severe squads of the enemy broke through
our line in several places and the fight
was literally hand to hand it did not
seem possible to withstand another shock
like this now coming on our loss had
been severe one half of my left wing had
fallen and a third of my regiment lay
behind us dead or badly wounded
at this moment my anxiety was increased
by a great Roar of musketry in my rear
on the farther or Northerly slope of
little round top apparently on the flank
of the regular Brigade which was in
support of hazlett's battery on the
crust behind us the bullets from this
attack struck into my left rear and I
feared that the enemy might have nearly
surrounded the little round top and only
a desperate chance was left for us
my ammunition was soon exhausted my men
were firing their last shot and getting
ready to club with their muskets
it was imperative to strike before we
were struck by this overwhelming force
in a hand-to-hand fight which we could
not probably have withstood or survived
at that crisis
I ordered the bayonet
the word was enough it ran like fire
along the line from man to man and Rose
into a shout with which they sprang
forward upon the enemy now not 30 yards
away
[Music]
the effect was surprising many of the
enemy's first line threw down their arms
and surrendered
an officer fired his pistol at my head
with one hand while he handed me his
sword with the other
holding fast by our right and Swinging
forward our left we made an extended
right wheel before the enemy's second
line broke and fell back fighting from
tree to tree many being captured until
we had swept the valley and cleared the
front of nearly our entire Brigade
meantime Captain Morel with his
skirmishes sent out from my Left Flank
with some dozen or 15 of the U.S
Sharpshooters who had put themselves
under his Direction fell upon the enemy
as they were breaking and by his
demonstrations as well as his
well-directed fire added much to the
effect of the charge
having thus cleared the valley and
driven the enemy up the western slope of
the great Round Top not wishing to press
so far as out to Hazard the ground I was
to hold by leaving exposed to a sudden
Rush of the enemy I succeeded although
with some effort to stop my men who
declared they were on the road to
Richmond in getting the regiment into
good order and resuming our original
position
400 prisoners including two field and
several line officers were sent to the
rear
these were mainly from the 15th and 47th
Alabama reg regiments with some of the
fourth and fifth Texas
150 of the enemy were found killed and
wounded in our front
so there you go
and that resulted in as he said 150
enemy killed about 400 prisoners
the 20th Maine had over a hundred
wounded and they had
30. who were killed in action
and this is uh you know Joshua
Chamberlain is receives the Medal of
Honor for this this bayonet charge
and that holds the flank
yeah uh I mean just an incredible
uh of what you know one uh for for
strong Vincent you know he's a uh he's a
brigade Commander as a colonel uh and
and like I said you know you're supposed
to go to the wheat field and you know
when you read about Chamberlain of why
are they low on ammunition
because their Logistics sheep thinks
they're in the wheat field
so where are they sending logs to that
you know what I mean and it's no that's
no like nothing against like strong
Vincent man I mean that's like the LA
like these dude like when I stand up
there man and you you're just like when
we're there you're you're looking down
at Wheat Field peach orchard like you
know Devil's Den Round Top you know I
mean just all these events that's going
on yeah Logistics is probably the last
freaking thing on my mind man uh and you
know when you uh spoken there of strong
fencing I mean he gets killed you know
you lose him up there patio Rourke with
New York you know he goes down I mean
there's Carnage going on I mean the
alabamans and Texans man it's not like I
mean they're attacking multiple times
and and you and I have walked up that
that same approach route
uh the Texas and Alabama that is not an
easy route that I would want to take uh
I mean it's just so on on both sides but
man you know with the 20th main uh and
then with like that Captain Morel and
you know you and you mentioned there
because we didn't really talk about it
just because I mean there's like so much
stuff to talk about at Gettysburg but
yeah there's badan Sharpshooters uh that
were over there on the south end of the
battlefield and it was also the first
time that anybody was allowed to wear
green uniforms was the perdan
Sharpshooters so that's where you get
your army OD Green comes from the berdan
Sharpshooters and these dudes can lay
the wood with a rifle uh and as their
you know Sharp Shooting against the
Confederates they're kind of making
their way up and over the big round top
because they don't want to come through
friendly lines you know nobody wearing a
green tree suit wants to go through
friendly lines it's not a good idea even
still today so they jump in and join in
with Captain morale so I mean just the
actions of 20th Maine uh and and you
know uh you guys have heard uh quite a
bit about Chamberlain so far not just at
Gettysburg but uh you know at the other
battles and stuff I mean this guy to get
folks to to you know do a where he only
gets to say bayonet
you know and uh
like we encourage all of you all
to to make your way to Gettysburg and
mount that rock
I mean if there's like one rock that you
want to get on
dude that's it you know what I mean like
because you get a whole different
perspective yeah like just what is it
like four feet up yeah probably a four
foot tall Rock and you can you're
standing on the ground and you're
looking you're like well I can I'm not
really sure what's over there can't
really see this area there's Dead Space
over there but then you step on that
rock and it just oh totally changes your
perspective yeah
you got you got to get all the rock yeah
and you might feel it a little bit too
when you step up on the Rock dude I love
run into that rock that's always I mean
I love that rock
uh like you just said I mean there's so
much going on and you know I mentioned
it earlier when I was talking about uh
uh Rhodes book like he he throws out a
sentence that's like yeah we fought in
the woods for an hour at close fire and
hand-to-hand combat like that's
happening all over the place like like
for for like a couple square miles is
people engaged in close combat heroics
and all kinds of different levels uh and
when you start talking about heroics
that we can't talk about all of them
but you got to talk about the first
Minnesota right I mean you just have to
talk about the first Minnesota and what
they did because you got
as this as this echelon attack is
happening it's in some places is working
oh yeah especially people that stuck
with the plan because there's some
people that didn't decided not to
execute you know you were talking about
the morale earlier
and you know you had Long Street that's
kind of executed but kind of like did it
on a slow roll the original unoriginal
plan you got some of these Confederate
forces that are like oh we're not going
okay we're not going yeah
some of them went some of them made
progress uh there's a brigade from
Georgia that actually starts to break
through and is making their way
up
up Cemetery up towards Cemetery Ridge
like they're gonna get there oh yeah
like I mean it's I mean they're there uh
and when you stand it because it's like
really flat right there at that area you
know what I mean and it's not it's not
very proud but it is when you go to the
east it does drop off pretty primarily
back there to that road and like you
said this draw play on this massive
scale is working uh
so yeah these George guys they're gonna
start seeing and now now we're over in
uh over in the in the second core area
and that's Hancock so this is like his
area of line of responsibility but
they're also you know I mean there's
like you said man there's just so much
stuff going on because oh by the way
while that draw play is going on then
what's gonna kick off over here towards
the copes Hill well now here comes Mead
I mean Mead's got to deal with these
guys because he's got Yule that's now
going to start executing his draw play
uh so it's just like holy [__] man you
know what I mean like there's a lot of
stuff going on and as as Hancock is
riding the lines you know what I mean
he's up and like and everybody like I
mean when you when you get the picture
of the the the Union Generals uh at
Gettysburg even on day two man like it's
not like you gotta go far to find one
they're all up there on a lot like I
mean it's you know you got folks moving
in and around pulling troops pushing
troops because it's chaos
and Hancock sees to where these folks
are about ready they're they're getting
up onto the cemetery Ridge and as more
resources are pulling up here comes this
unit and it's the first Minnesota
uh and and it's part in first Minnesota
I mean pull the string on those guys
they're the reason why they're first
they are the first regiment from the
state of Minnesota these dudes have been
in the war since the beginning they are
a very proud unit uh from Minnesota uh
and there's there's some people that
think that if it wasn't for the first
Minnesota
you know I mean it could have been a
different outcome uh definitely uh with
the Battle of Gettysburg for what these
guys so how they end up uh getting into
this uh Winfield Scott is seeing this
and he knows that it's going to be a
disaster and he and he looks over uh and
and he sees and he's he yells down at
the Minnesota he doesn't know who they
are but he just sees a freaking Regiment
of it and he's like who who is that and
of course Colville a colonel first
Minnesota you know what I mean he's like
like of course it is the first month
like these dudes are like first
Minnesota and he looks and he says you
see those colors pointing at the
Georgians right he's pointing at him you
know what I mean you see take those
colors
and I mean so the Minnesota and it's not
going to go you got just just to throw
some numbers out yeah throw some numbers
I mean what how how many uh how many
guys we got in the first Minnesota at
this point like 250 yeah just less than
300 and and how many are in this brigade
of Georgians
thousand yeah close to a thousand yeah I
mean because yeah yeah go to the numbers
because at the beginning of the war like
a regiment's supposed to have a thousand
people dude we're in 63. we've had a lot
there's not a thousand people they got
just under 300. well as you just covered
I mean it's like it just go going back
to the book Gettysburg here uh
Hancock broke from his thoughts and
looked at the first Minnesota as if for
the first time my God he exclaimed are
these all the men we have here he
demanded to know and was told the
regiment's name Colonel do you see those
colors he asked Colville Colville like
you said is the Minnesota Commander
pointing to the name pointing to some of
the Rebel battle Flags bobbing among
wilcox's Brigade when Colville said he
did Hancock gave his orders then take
them
the first Minnesota moved down the
gentle slope
bayonets fixed a line of battle perhaps
a hundred yards from end to end the
soldiers came under Fire right away men
stumbled and fell recalled an officer in
those ranks some stayed down but others
got up and continued the charging line
of minnesotans drove into the advanced
screen of wilcox's Brigade and hustled
it back to a second line which fell back
to the main body
this last some 1 000 strong was not
going to be scattered by 250 or so
Yankees
the men of the first Minnesota halted
along the dry stream bed of Plum run
firing for all they were worth
a torrent of Confederate rifle fire
lashed into the Yankee regiment from
wilcox's men and in their front and from
some of the Lang's Florida troops who
got an inflate position
after enduring a few minutes of this the
union survivors ran back to cemetery
Ridge
this was the final straw for Cadmus
Wilcox his request for reinforcements
had not been answered and both his
flanks were exposed without support on
either my right or left he reported my
men were withdrawn to prevent their
entire destruction or capture
and the Minnesota I mean they took like
somewhere around 80 percent losses yeah
yeah it's anywhere between 80 83 percent
and and you know what they were most
proud of
everybody was present
nobody stayed back
I mean the Minnesota one goes man they
all went
uh yeah I mean and it and that that
Monument that's there for the first
Minnesota because you know it's it's
right there next to the biggest Monument
on the freaking Battlefield you know
that big white domey thing of
Pennsylvania because the pennsylvanians
are proud of their boys that fought
there which yeah of course uh but that
Minnesota man it's just it's it's a cool
Monument just because it's just one
Rifleman and he's like you know he's
carrying his rival he's kind of like
bent over like he's in that charge man
it's just one dude man running right
into that melee and and he's
representing like all of Minnesota I
mean it's uh
it's just I mean it's incredible uh like
you said I mean there's just so many
acts of just complete just bravery and
Leadership I mean we could spend just
years up there uh you know what I mean
it's just it's so yeah
um well you know the Minnesota the first
Minnesota is able to stop that's the
closest that they get to breaking
through the lines and they were halted
by these 250 a thousand were stopped by
250 Minnesota and and that was kind of
the closest they got day this is day two
and that kind of closes out
day two like this is they're kind of
there they're kind of backed on they're
back they're kind of back to where they
started at the end of day two really not
not a lot of progress has been made
there's been a lot of fighting there's
been a lot of death but you end up with
you know Seminary Ridge you end up with
Lee and the and the Confederates over
there on Seminary Ridge again and on
Cemetery Ridge you got the fish hook uh
that's where you end up with
at the at the end of
at the end of day two now worth
mentioning
but Minnesota were close to breaking
through but also like in the center of
the line where Lee was watching there
was another Brigade that almost broke
through
right yeah he's he's over at his
headquarters and you could see so as as
he watches this this one Brigade break
through the lines there you know what I
mean and like get into the lot I mean
these guys are in the lines with
Minnesota in them they're they're on
Seminary on Cemetery Ridge they're in
the lines and Lee it has a profound
effect uh on Robert E Lee and just like
you said like you know just like HUD
going for the round tops not doing what
he's told some folks just decided I'm
just not going to attack and you know
kindness Wilcox has to pull back out
same thing's happening over on copes
Hill with that whole thing with Yule
folks are just deciding yeah just not
gonna attack you know what I mean so
this is like this is something this
hasn't happened in the army of Northern
Virginia but yeah Lee is observing uh
you know what I mean and he sees this
brigade
that is successful
so Lee thinks because as everybody's
like pulling back like you said day two
we're done so everybody's gotta like get
what they can and make their way back to
their original starting positions so
literally we're right back like you had
said Seminary Cemetery everybody's back
to where they were except now we've got
folks occupying and we're gonna we're
gonna keep them up on the little right
on top like okay well once we got it
we're gonna keep it uh so at good call
I don't want to give that up again but
you could imagine I mean there's a lot
of loss I mean these armies are getting
pretty wrecked so the lines are going to
start to get pretty thin I mean when
you've got a regimen of first Minnesota
and you're taking over 80 percent
casualties I mean so the lines are
getting thin uh but you know the the
union Army's got good resupply coming in
now you got to look at the resupply
that's coming in over with the army of
Northern Virginia you know I mean I I
they're getting kind of low so
Lee's got to come up with another plan
and he's got to bring his core
commanders back in that night because
he's got to issue another order right uh
so Lee as he's observing the day battle
and he's got a pretty good vantage point
to observe that uh
he's like dude if one Brigade can get
through that line
what if I stuff 11 brigades through the
center line
so here comes Pickett's Charge
so that's why
on day three
what he sees happened successfully on
day two
I'm gonna stuff 11 brigades right across
that three quarters of a mile right in
the middle frontal assault frontal
assault man
uh and
you know so so you've got Long Street in
there so I mean you know how that kind
of went down on on uh on July the second
Long Street when he showed up he he
wasn't on board with the plan
uh and then goes out you know slow rolls
whatever you know what I mean it gets
all the way out and around it goes from
200 people into peach orchard a couple
of thousand people in the peach orchard
hood is he's not doing what he's told
you got other guys that are refusing to
advance I mean it's just like what what
yeah like what's going on with the army
of Northern Virginia here and and now
I can only imagine so long Street walks
into the tent he's like hey boss yeah
but it wasn't a good day yep no [__] uh
but I could imagine like Long Street is
might be looking at it like
what do you want to do today and then
Lee's going to say I want to stuff 11
brigades yeah you would think Long
Street would be like hey you know Boss
look we took a crack at it might be a
good idea you remember what I was
talking about a couple days ago like how
about we move somewhere else to get
defensive what do you think boss like
this isn't working out too well that's
what I would be hoping for if I was Long
Street right but that's not what he gets
no he gets we're gonna do a frontal
assault
straight straight up the middle
so you know Long Street pushes back
against that plan
yeah and and luckily we got some
documentation here for once again going
back to this book Gettysburg you know if
you
how strongly does he push back against
you know General Lee who is the
Confederacy at this point right here's
what Long Street tells him
General
I have been a soldier all my life
I've been with soldiers engaged in
fights by couples by squads companies
regiments divisions and armies
and should know as well as anyone what
soldiers can do
it is my opinion that no 15
000 men ever arrayed for battle can take
that position
and the next line in the book is Lee was
unmoved
that unmute which is crazy to think
about like this is I mean even guys that
I didn't really you know if I had one of
my supporters come to me and say hey
Jacob look the plan that you just came
up with I've been doing this for a while
this ain't gonna work
even if I didn't know that you know even
if my trust level was low I'd be like oh
damn it's gonna make me reconsider some
stuff so the fact that Lee is just like
unmoved
it's scary to think about it's scary to
think about and I'll tell you what when
you go over and you stand on on the
Confederate side and you look up across
that field
uh it's it's a nightmare it's a
nightmare you got this big open field
there's barely any cover they got these
um
they got these fences right like these
these these fences out there that are
gonna bog you down
the the unions in like a little bit of
an elevated position where they're
shooting down I mean it's it's a
nightmare
but that's the command
yeah and and the the funny thing is is
like even though Long Street makes that
response and it's crazy that Lee is
unmoved
and then who's he going to pick to be in
charge of all of this long Street
so again you got a guy that is not like
yeah I mean he's definitely not on board
with the plan
so then he's got to go and he's got to
coordinate with AP Hill because he's
going to take some of his guys too I
mean this is like you said I mean he's
over 12 000 people I mean I
when you look at that field the the
front it like people think like when you
think about it oh let's just pick its
charge you know they're all just going
to be in this little tight no I mean
it's across the field Frontage you know
what I mean and they're gonna come up
out of like okay yeah I'll give there's
a little bit of defilate yeah there's
some some little areas little areas but
you better be skull dragging and wearing
a ghillie suit man like if you think
you're gonna get across that field
unscathed yeah and then you know we talk
about like uh it's now you're coming
into July 3rd you've been out there
fighting a battle for a couple of days
right and and you've we don't have
smokeless gunpowder yet either do we so
there's no wind it's freaking hot it's
humid it's July so all of that just
smoke is just sitting in that low area
across the fields because to kick this
thing off
just like a lot of uh infantry attacks
kick off they kick it off with
bombardment with a massive Cannon
bombardment and that that's what the
that's what the Confederates do but like
you said
well when you shoot a cannon you look at
where you hit and then you make some
adjustments right
well when everything is covered by smoke
you're only getting a couple rounds off
before you can't really even see what
you're shooting at anymore
yeah so your effective fire like you
know in today's day and age dude you
could have like the artillery yeah all
the way back over in the Cumberland
Valley and you got an fo guys and we
could be calling in Artie and you don't
even know where they are well back then
this is just like a big ass rifle on
wheels it's got like even a little peep
sight you know what I mean like on the
front of it and it's got like one of
those little silky like silky chairs
like on a tractor you know what I mean
so you got the guy and he's gonna cite
the piece so I mean and I got to be able
to see Jocko and I gotta cite it and
then I gotta you know I mean so there's
a lot going on here and then you know
one of the other things that we didn't
bring up that we always talk about when
we're over on McPherson's Ridge of range
estimation
you know what I mean so you're talking
about range estimation and like nowadays
you know we got like leica's and cool
stuff with like laser range Fighters
like everybody's got one you know I mean
back then it's kind of like you're
looking at it and it's like
yeah so you like you got to look at like
large objects well in Farmland the most
prominent features on these battlefields
are barns right so you got a barn and uh
and the barns if you're from the south
the barns are like two-story right you
know what I mean so when you're looking
at your if you're from North Carolina
you're looking at a barn any you know
whether you're shooting a rifle or
you're shooting an artillery piece
you're like hey that Barn you probably
hold out your fingers you're like hey
for me when I hold up my finger to a
barn if my if my finger can cover both
stories that's this many yards away if
it's a half of my finger oh it's this
many yards away if it's if it's really
close oh that's it it takes two fingers
a cup so you get a way to sense like
same thing happens with hunting like elk
right if you can as often as you can you
go out and you look at and you shoot at
life-size elk targets because after a
while you go oh I can see I can just a
quick estimation like oh I can see how
big it is just by understanding
the size of an elk and how big it is in
my vision right now okay that thing's 80
yards away oh look look at this other
one over here oh that thing's this big
in my vision it's 40 yards away so these
these guys get used to you're in the
South you're looking at a barn you know
that the things roughly what's two
stories but it's 20 feet 20 22 feet you
know what it is and you can rate do
range estimation on that right so the
army of Northern Virginia
has how many times have they been North
so far once for one day right and they
got out one day and they only saw a
couple of Arts you know what I mean uh
so now they're back up there again well
you know I mean I I live in Virginia the
Barnes in Virginia
are smaller than the Barnes and
Gettysburg because it gets cold up there
so they've got that bottom story to
where they can put the livestock
underneath there and we're out there at
like McPherson's Ridge because we always
go back and around the back side of the
barn and you can now see it
yeah you know what I mean so range
estimation is going to be a big deal
you know I mean it's called a mess yeah
you know what I mean because it appears
to be closer so you're going to Short
Round it you know what I mean and these
guys are only three quarters of a mile
so it doesn't matter if you're the green
tubes you know that are out there or the
Napoleon style artillery still three
quarters of a mile the black tubes are
painted black because they're steel so
for erosion those are still a mile a
mile and a half guns you know what I
mean but you still have to see yeah you
know what I mean and you're still going
to cut for the range estimation of how
far you want this big massive ball to
blow up right so it's it's going to be
off so that's going to be a huge effect
on the army of Northern Virginia as well
and they're just gonna yeah they're
gonna start with that artillery barrage
and then it's
Here Comes Pickett's Charge
picket's charge is like you said it's 12
500 men
they're going look is there some is
there some places to hide along the way
is there is there a a little null to get
behind is there some Dead Space you can
work through yes but eventually if
you're going to move forward you're
gonna have to get up and you're gonna
have that so there's very little cover
there's not even that much concealment
it's three quarters of a mile there's
these split rail fences that you're
bogged down on you have to either break
it which is going to take you time or
you gotta climb over it now you're even
more exposed
and this just turns into a a death march
as they move forward
yeah it's uh
you know as they now
do they make it all the way across the
field yeah some of them do some of them
but um it's not enough to to make any
matter and and uh a lot of folks you
know when you read you always get to the
you know the high water mark of the
Confederacy that's over there and it's
not it's just like that it's that little
bitty white like marble looking like
looks like a scroll and that is where
like what makes it uh even even more
famous is that's where Armistead and
Hancock
their friends
so that's where Armistead Falls and dies
and literally Hancock comes out but that
that high water mark of the of the
Confederacy that's as far north as they
ever got
yeah and uh
like it's a death it's a field of death
but like you said some of them do make
it there's hand-to-hand combat and you
know you go there it's amazing because
you're like standing at the stone wall
where
some of the Confederates made it over
that wall they're in there they're
killing each other with band it's like
the fact that they made it that far is
incredible but once they got there
that was it the guys that made it there
were the guys that made it there there
was no one else coming yeah yeah nobody
and and the thing about it is like at
that high water mark how far would you
say we're actually from Meats
headquarters
500 yards no more than 500 years I mean
it's like literally right over the
military crash right you're there I mean
that's how close these dudes are and it
it yeah it looks like like nowadays I
mean it's just like just I mean it's a
beautiful Battlefield Park but I mean
that day at the end of Pickett's Charge
man of what's taking place in the center
of those lines is just
freaking Carnage you know uh so yeah
it's uh
it was game on so that yeah so when you
when you go there when you hear the the
referral of the high water mark and the
and the cops of trees uh that people
talk about those cops of trees are just
like uh just a little bit off to the
left of the high water Mark it's just
like this and you can't miss it because
the Park Service put a big like wrought
iron fence around the cops of trees
those cops of trees is where it's it's
supposed to be the trees that are high
enough because like when Jocko and I
were kind of talking a little bit
earlier about like you can't really see
stuff but the trees are up above all the
smoke and stuff so it's giving you a
guide so while you're trying to get
across this field you can at least see
those trees in the distance and there's
debate over whether or not it was those
cops of trees or whether it doesn't make
a [__] you know I mean there there's
trees and it's like a guiding because
once they go it's like as everybody goes
towards the cops of trees that's why
everybody's kind of funneling in to that
center of the line and then that's where
you get the high water mark of the
Confederacy so that's how like when
you're reading through the book and
you're trying to like kind of figure out
your head of like what's going on you
know if you if you if you come out to
Gettysburg and you you see it like all
of it just bam it just comes right to
you and it's amazing
uh you know what I mean that you know
that's pretty much the end of day three
you know what I mean uh and then you
you've got the high water mark and then
you're looking at the casualties of that
day with you know you're starting out
you get you're sending across 12 500
folks
I mean that's a lot of people but you
could imagine at the end of day three
man of the Battle of Gettysburg
yeah I mean just just on that it's 1
123 killed four thousand so like half
and three thousand seven hundred and
fifty captured so more than half of your
troops
are gone
um or they're at least casualties that
aren't going to be able to fight anymore
and
you know you you it's so frustrating
when you look at that Battlefield and
you know you understand you know this is
this is about leadership and just that
to to know that the relationship wasn't
there
you know when again look if you're a
historian and you want to pull up some
letters that I don't know about okay
from my perspective as I look at the
relationship between Long Street and Lee
They didn't have a good enough
relationship where where Lee is going to
listen to Long Street and say hey
I'm giving you the strongest possible
personal recommendation not to do this
and
Lee says no we're doing it
and and then you just send you know half
of your men to be wounded killed or
captured uh it's it's horrible thing to
look at and it's it's a very
pressing thought from a leadership
perspective
so
yeah like you said I mean this is the
after that the the Confederate moves
back and and basically day the next day
they get up and they start their Retreat
to the South
and I mean Lincoln Lincoln's fired up
it's like hey pursue
it means like
yeah boss okay you know we'll do our
best but I mean there's
the the casualties on the union side are
absolutely immense
and so
it's a win
it's a it's it's definitely a win for
the union now interestingly you would
think that this would be the big news of
the day
you would think you would think that
this would be the big news today
generally the most respected military
commander out there on either side just
got defeated the people that are on the
the Confederates who've been on a
winning streak winning streak winning
streak winning streak all sudden they've
been defeated you would think that this
would be the big story but the big story
actually isn't
Gettysburg the big story is what happens
on July 4th in Vicksburg and that is
that Vicksburg Falls It's Been Under
Siege
and Vicksburg Falls
uh
grant our boy Grant is out there and
he's like proven his leadership skills
and this puts you know Grant or puts
link into a position he's you know he's
paying attention see who's got it that's
out there kicking ass and he's starting
to see Grant as a guy that's out there
kicking ass and Lincoln's thinking
I'm gonna bring this guy back east
and and let him take over all the armies
uh so even though but even though this
wasn't the story of the day
um certainly
this became this battle became Legend
and
you know years later
at a dedication uh to a memorial to the
20th main on little round top uh Joshua
Lawrence Chamberlain he he gave a speech
up there
and this this speech you know just to
give a little a little small excerpt of
this speech
of what he said
he said this
we Rose in Soul
above the things which even the
Declaration of Independence pronounces
the inalienable rights of human nature
for the securing of which governments
are instituted among men
happiness Liberty life we laid on the
altar of offering or committed to the
furies of Destruction while our minds
were lifted up to a great thought
and our hearts swelled to its measure
we were beckoned on by the vision of
Destiny we saw our country moving
forward charged with the sacred trusts
of man
we believed in its glorious career the
power of high aims and strong purpose
the continuity
of great endeavor
the onward upward path of History to God
every man felt that he gave himself to
and belonged to something Beyond Time
and above place
something which could not die
so all those things that in the
Declaration of Independence life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness these men
on that ground
put all those things on the altar of
sacrifice
and yet despite all that suffering and
all that sacrifice the war was not over
then there would be more suffering and
there would be more sacrifice required
in order to preserve the Union
and we will continue that on the next
civil war
Excursion
and that's the plan so we've got to
July of 1863. we have we have to go all
the way until April of 1865.
um
it's going to start to turn into the Lee
versus Grant story
we're going to start seeing Sherman back
in the game
uh we've been here JD and I have been
here uh for a week out in out here in
San Diego California doing this uh we we
aren't going to be able to do this
immediately
but the plan is in the next several
months will come out and we'll give you
the second half of what's going on the
second half of how this unfolds
some of these details some of these
Lessons Learned you know you know JD
it's uh so awesome to be able to sit
here with you because
you know I I'm a jiu jitsu guy probably
if there's well I guess I know I know
probably the best skill I have or no but
the most knowledge I have is probably
about
maneuvering elements on a battlefield
small elements my own about that's
probably the most knowledgeable thing I
have because that was my profession for
a long time but jiu jitsu's right up
there
and like when I'm learning Jiu Jitsu if
I'm learning a new move and and somebody
shows me something
for me because I have a lot of
experience and a lot of knowledge a lot
of context I can take that move and I
can incorporate it usually pretty quick
and what I love about having you here
is the context that you have around this
information is like incredible and it's
not just a it's not what I really like
about is not just a mental picture that
you have you don't just have like hey I
know this character I know that
character you have an unmatched terrain
Association where where when when we're
talking about a place on the battlefield
you're you know that you've been in that
place you've you've been in that place
like when we're talking about Vicksburg
we just threw a random a random
Vicksburg we haven't talked about
Vicksburg yet we're just throwing a
random thing out there about Vicksburg
The Siege ending and the Confederacy
falling you're like you know where that
happened you've walked those grounds
you've been through that so it's awesome
to be able to sit here and have you
share that context and all these
different things man so I appreciate you
coming out to do this I appreciate you
having me out man this is a huge uh
great experience man being on here and
and again you know uh like I've told you
numerous times when you read Chamberlain
and the folks that are out there and the
characters that we're tired I mean these
are great Americans man like everybody
in America should know who John frickin
Beaufort is man they should know
Chamberlain they should know Mead you
know as many times as like we've done
staff rides together and you know like
the the first day when everyone he gets
there first thing we're always like is
like hey put your hand in the air if you
know who George Gordon meat is nobody
puts their hand in the air I say well
who knows Robert E Lee the whole room
goes up but it's like he beat Robert E
Lee here like he fought for the union
man like Mead you know I mean it's a
great guy Hancock you know I mean we
talked about that stuff earlier today
like I mean you don't know who hand I
mean these are just Great America so I
mean dude well I love being on here with
you man and and and you know folks can
learn and hopefully you know get these
books man and read through them I mean
they are just phenomenal yeah a caveat
that I should have put out like on the
first one that we did
is you know look first of all we can't
cover everything you know we we just
can't cover everything and we know that
there's stuff we're skipping over we
know that there's letters that were
written that we didn't there's just all
this stuff to to go through and you
could see I mean we're on Gettysburg
today this was that we're at three hours
and 42 minutes by the way right now so 3
hours and 42 minutes we could have done
this we could have done seven eight
hours on it I mean when we go to the
battlefield when we go to Gettysburg we
do eight hours a day plus dinner plus
bro like we're just it's like 28 hours
of freaking Gettysburg just Gettysburg
so that's the caveat also look look like
obviously I'm I'm not I'm much less
knowledgeable than you I'm throwing in
my spin so if anyone's mad that I said
Lee thought this or or you know Long
Street thought that or Chamberlain
should have done this I apologize for my
opinions that's my assessment
um sorry
you know don't don't subscribe you know
but those are my hey it's my podcast
I'll have my opinions but but honestly
not that it's my podcast I'll have my
opinions but for me I always want to
know from a leadership perspective from
a human nature perspective what can I
glean from what I see and if I'm not
trying to figure it out well then I'm
not in my opinion I'm not trying to put
my context around I don't have the
context that you have around the the the
the actual characters the actual terrain
but I got care you know I've got my
contacts of interacting with a bunch of
people for a long time so I apologize to
anyone out there that's mad about some
take I had on something uh that's my
take man and hey if I'm I look for I'm
sure a lot of people will reach out and
say Hey you know
Lee never would have said that because
of X I will appreciate that feedback I'm
open to I'm obviously open to it I know
I don't know everything uh but seriously
there's so many lessons to learn in
these and and going to these places look
do you do you want to come and go
through one of these Battlegrounds with
Echelon front sure do you want to go
with omna International which is JD's
company sure if you don't go with us you
don't need us there
I would just encourage you to go out
walk these battlefields I mean this when
you look at the elevation the elevated
Vision that Chamberlain has of this
country
and you realize that's what these guys
were striving for now look was every
private striving for this elevated
Vision no no I get that is every you
know Lance Lance corporal in the Marine
Corps is every private in the Army got
this elevated vision of of of
America and that's what they're fighting
for no not all of them but I'll tell you
what you take a unit and that elevated
vision of America is there
and that's what these men fought for
and so you go out pay respect on these
battlefields and you're going to take
away something not just about leadership
not just about combat but you're going
to learn to appreciate what sacrifices
were made so that we could carry on this
incredible nation that we have
anything else JD that's that's it man
love it awesome that's the plan
everybody we'll see in a few months
for the rest of the Jocko Excursion
Civil War podcast with JD Baker in the
meantime if you want to support go to
jocklestore.com jockoffuel.com
originusa.com
front.com the omna.com
we appreciate it and until next time
Stay Free
this is JD and Jocko out